Was sagst du über Religion? Es gibt keine Religion ohne Freiheit, aber es gibt keine Freiheit ohne Religion.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 94 und außerdem ist es die dritte Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express live auf Funkwelle FM. Wir senden hier nicht nur live im Internet über das Streaming auf unserem Streaming-Server streamscenim.de, sondern wir senden auch auf UKW, wie jeden Sonntag. Jeden Sonntag ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Jetzt kommt noch ein einziger Termin dazu, zusätzlich zu heute, und hier geht es immer zwei Stunden live von 15 bis 17 Uhr, um die Themen, um die es bei Chaosradio Express ohnehin geht. Für die Neueinsteiger sei noch mal kurz erwähnt, Chaosradio Express ist ein Podcast, das heißt, normalerweise gibt es uns nur abonnierbar im Internet, von Zeit zu Zeit eben dann halt auch mal live, so wie jetzt. Und Informationen zu dem Podcast und auch den ganzen anderen Podcasts vom Chaos Computer Club findet ihr auf chaosradio.ccc.de und mitdiskutieren könnt ihr auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Das ist das Blog zur Sendung und da kann man dann Kommentare hinterlassen und sich beschweren oder sonst irgendwelche Anmerkungen machen zu dem, was hier geschieht. Ja, nochmal hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit einem tollen Thema. Wir haben heute den 10. August 2008 und der Spiegel ist gerade erschienen. Wenn man jetzt in die Tankstelle fährt, dann kann man sich schon die neue Ausgabe kaufen. Da prang ganz groß drauf, so in Google-Optik der Titel macht das Internet doof. Das ist eine gute Frage und die wollen wir uns heute auch stellen, denn das Thema soll heute sein Conversational Design, ein recht neuer Begriff. Mal gucken, ob er verfängt und mehr dazu sagt mir hoffentlich heute im Laufe der Sendung zu meiner Rechten Kosmar. Hallo Kosmar. Ja, du bist ja so ein, wie soll man das sagen, du bist so eine Art neuzeitliches Urgestein des Internets, ein Power-User der Internetdienste aller Art. Wir hatten schon vor einiger Zeit bei Chaosradio mal eine Sendung zum Thema Web 2.0, als das alles noch ganz frisch und neu war, hatte ich Felix und Stefan da von places.com, mit dem wir dann schön philosophiert haben, welche Möglichkeiten denn die neuen Dienste alle so bieten werden und was da so die Dynamik dahinter ist. Das war so am Anfang. Jetzt sind einige Jahre vergangen und ich dachte mir, es wäre mal ganz angemessen, einen kurzen Blick zurück und auch in die aktuelle Zeit zu werfen, um zu verstehen, was denn jetzt eigentlich passiert ist im Internet. Das Internet ist ja an sich nichts Neues. Das gibt es nun schon recht lange, gut noch nicht so lange wie das Telefon, aber man hatte jetzt einige Zeit, sich daran zu gewöhnen, was es denn alles so mitbringt und für viele Leute sind so Sachen wie E-Mail und natürlich das Abrufen von Webseiten zu einer Selbstverständlichkeit geworden. Man verlässt sich in gewisser Hinsicht darauf, aber neu ist halt der Trend, komplexere Dienste meist basierend auf Webseiten aufzusetzen. Das ist das, was so unter dem Schlagwort Web 2.0 eingeführt wurde und das ist ja, das ist das, was unser Thema heute sein soll. Das wollen wir hier ein bisschen besprechen, aber ich denke, wir fangen erstmal mit dir an, Kosmar selber, dass du vielleicht mal kurz sagst, wie du eigentlich so deinen Weg in die Computerwelt gefunden hast. Bist du auch schon mit der Flasche aufgezogen worden?
Gar nicht eigentlich. Also ich hatte damals, mein erster Computer war so ein VC20 Commodore, aber dann hatte ich lange auch gar keinen, sondern war immer zum Spielen bei Freunden, mit Atari und Amiga.
Da teilst du das Schicksal aber mit vielen Leuten, die heutzutage das Netz mitgestalten.
Vor Hause hatte ich dann immer den, der schon ganz alt ist. Den hat mein Vater mir als Neuer verkauft.
Verstehe, du bist sozusagen die Müllhalde gewesen. Papi hat sich dann immer die neuesten Schnickes gekauft und du durftest die Zweiverwertung machen.
Und dann, als dann irgendwann klar war, dass ich Grafikdesigner werde, dann habe ich mir auch ein Mac gekauft. Schon noch, bevor ich da gelernt habe.
Von welchem Jahr reden wir denn jetzt eigentlich?
Das war so 1994, 1995 oder so.
Auch der 1420 kam erst 1994 auf den Tisch.
Das war schon ein bisschen früher. Ich habe schon auch Basic geschrieben, ohne Englisch zu können. Also abgetippt, ohne zu wissen, was es heißt.
Programm-Listings.
Das aus Zeitschriften kopiert. Aber dann habe ich echt lange noch nichts gemacht. Ich hatte auch nie einen PC, also Windows hatte ich nie bisher. Das war mehr so ein Werkzeug für mich als Grafiker.
Du wolltest immer schon Designer werden.
Ja, das war relativ schnell klar. Also das war, wie das in der Schule dann so ist. Du machst dann Kunst-LK. Und das machst du dann ganz gerne und weißt irgendwie, mit den Augen kannst du ganz gut denken. Und dann hatte ich irgendwann einen Ausbildungsplatz, also einen Berufsschulplatz für Grafikdesign. Es gibt nicht so viele Schulen, die so was machen, so drei Jahre Schule. Und dann kam es der Zivildienst und mal überlegt, ob man das auch studieren will oder nicht. Aber das war mir alles viel zu aufwählen. Ich habe dann das gemacht und dann direkt nach Berlin gekommen danach und vom Praktikant dann in einer Online-Agentur angefangen. Das war dann 1995.
Das heißt, du bist eigentlich so genau, als das Internet so seine erste richtige breite Welle entfaltet hat, schon in die erste Reihe vorgerückt?
Wir haben damals Metacrawler war die Suchmaschine und dann kam Google so nach meinem Praktikum quasi, kam das festlich. So das war so die Zeit. Und da bin ich dann geblieben, bis die Karriereleiter durchlaufen war und seitdem bin ich jetzt seit drei Jahren fast schon frei, also freier Web-Designer und Berater und arbeite eben für Agenturen.
Das heißt, du hast deine ersten Schritte mit Basic gemacht, aber du bist nicht wirklich beim Programmieren geblieben.
Nein, das nicht wirklich.
Die Technik ist nicht deine Welt.
Naja, ich weiß sozusagen, wie ein Architekt auch mal mauern muss, weiß ich schon, wie man die Webseiten baut und finde es auch wichtig, dass man das weiß. Und kann schon so eine IF-Schleife bauen quasi, aber nicht in allen Sprachen. Na klar. So ist das Verständnis eigentlich. Und interessiere mich eben, seitdem das Webber eben so die Stufe zum Teilnehmenden genommen hat, also was eben schon die Grundidee von Internet ist, dass jeder zum Sender wird und auch der Empfänger als Sender teilnimmt. Seit es eben populär ist, interessiere mich auch dafür und was eben unter Web 2.0 so landläufig gelistet wird.
In der kurzen Vorbesprechung hast du ja schon mir gesagt, so ja, okay, wir befinden uns jetzt hier sozusagen in der vierten Phase. Fand ich eine interessante Einteilung. Du hast es, vielleicht kannst du das ja noch mal kurz erläutern, wie da so deine Sicht der Dinge auf die Entwicklung im Internet ist.
Wenn man sich erinnert, so die am Anfang so Firmenpräsentationen waren ja immer so ins Netz gestellte Broschürchen, die auch tatsächlich inhaltlich daher rührten, oder es waren eben auch feste Texte, man hat es ja auch kaum geändert, es gab auch nicht Content-Management-System oder sowas. Es war ja das Hardcoded.
Also wenn wir von ins Netz gestellt reden, reden wir sozusagen vom World Wide Web.
Ja, und klar, also was dann die breite Sichtbarkeit von Internet, WWW ist. Das war so die Informationsebene, also du hast einfach nur Informationen publiziert, auch noch als Autorität, als nicht als Person, sondern als Firma oder als Institution. Und dann gab es eben auch E-Mail und dann hat man die beiden Sachen eben verknüpft irgendwann und dann gab es eben diesen Rückkanal und den hat man erkannt, dass er doch zu diesem Multimedium, das es damals ja schon so hieß und nicht wirklich war, noch so ein wichtiger Bestandteil ist, dass eben die Menschen auch durchaus zurückmelden können. Also dann so eine Kommunikationsstufe, wo du eben Feedback-Formular hast oder Kontakt aufnehmen kannst mit dem Absender.
Also E-Mail ist natürlich ein viel älterer Dienst als jetzt das Web, aber was du meinst, ist, dass das Web sozusagen dann auch erst mal seine User entdeckt hat und eben dieses Feedback als solches auch mit reingenommen hat. Das ist weg ist von der Broschüre hin zu so einer Broschüre, wo man sich auch darüber beschweren kann.
Schon ein bisschen Dialog, genau und das führt dann natürlich schnell dazu, dass man auch Sachen da verkaufen will. Also dann kam die dritte Stufe E-Commerce-Welle, im Prinzip dann schon späte 90er, wo es dann um Transaktion geht. Also ich verkaufe was und ich kann zum Teil auch Geld darüber schicken, online Banking und so kam dann auch auf und so was. Transaktionsebene und erstens.
Also im Prinzip Amazon muss man hier glaube ich erwähnen als wichtigste.
Auf Ebay damals schon.
Bei Ebay sicher schon insofern unterscheidet, als dass da das Verkaufen ja für jedermann möglich ist.
Genau, das war schon auch der Anfang von wirklicher Teilhabe. Also dass die Menschen an dem Medium im Teil haben im Sinne von wirklich auch selbst privaten Nutzen daraus nehmen. Also nicht nur durch Informationen und Nachschlagen und das große Gedächtnis und Bibliothek ersetzen, sondern auch selbst was sagen oder selbst was hergeben von sich und und selbst publizieren im Prinzip. Also eBay ist da schon was publizieren, ein eigener kleiner Shop und auch schon die Transaktionsstufe quasi für den Privatmenschen mit einbauen und sicher so ein erster Bestandteil von Partizipationen, also was eben die vierte Stufe dann ist, was wir jetzt so langsam erleben.
Also Information, Feedback, Transaktion, Partizipation und das ist das, wo wir uns jetzt befinden. Es gibt dieses schöne Schlagwort des Web 2.0, das ist ja mal aufgebracht worden von Tim O'Reilly, hat das glaube ich ins Feld geführt.
Es war einer seiner Mitarbeiter, die dann in so einem Brainstorming von der neue Konferenz-Typen-Reihe irgendwie den Begriff gefunden haben, wo dann eben ganz viel, weil sich in ganz vielen Ebenen und Ecken von Technologie bis eben Nutzer- verhalten auch Sachen verändert haben. So gerade in diese teilhabende Richtung, also auch technisch, so Standardisierung, um auch Daten austauschen zu können, einfacher, so das Einreißen von Mauern zwischen Diensten, Web-Services, Software als Service anbieten, mehr Sachen ins Netz zu verlagern, die sonst auf dem Rechner stattfinden. So all diese Dinge waren eben plötzlich da und auch gleichzeitig und eigentlich so unconnected zueinander. Und da haben die dann so den Begriff drüber gehoben, so als nächste Entwicklungsstufe, also diese Version.
Wie stehst du zu dem Begriff?
Na ja, erst mal ist er schönerweise eben so undefiniert gewesen damals, dass er eben alles, da konnte er alles rein. Und war dann natürlich ein Modebegriff und ein Marketingwort und interessant ist, es gab ja natürlich diese ganzen Passwörter auch vorher schon, also Konvergenz, E-Performance, E-Commerce und alles so. Also ich habe auch viele Präsentationen in meiner Agenturzeit geschrieben oder auch Projekten wochenlang mich mit so was beschäftigt. Aber das war dann immer nach einem halben Jahr auch vorbei. Barrierefreiheit war so vielleicht das letzte, was auch ein bisschen nachhaltiger war und auch schon einen richtigen Sinn im Medium selbst hat. Aber Web 2.0 so als Begriff, der hält doch jetzt schon über drei Jahre an.
Länger fast. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie alt der ist.
Diese Grafik auf Wikipedia, die habe ich im 05 gemacht, im November.
Diese Grafik, muss man mal kurz erwähnen, ich erinnere mich, die hast du mal gemacht. Das ist so eine Wolke, so eine Begriffswolke, wo du alle Buzzwords, die quasi mit Web 2.0 in irgendeiner Form was zu tun haben, reingeknallt hast.
Damals, ja.
Sind die eigentlich nur so angeordnet, damit sie überhaupt irgendwo stehen? Oder sind die so auch alle beieinander? Wo findet man diese Grafik?
Ich glaube, auf Wikipedia, auf dem Deutschen, ist es noch so im Original drauf.
Noch unter dem Begriff Web 2.0?
Und die zeigt so auf, wo eben da überall Bewegung war im Prinzip. Also das fängt eigentlich da unten rechts an mit Standardisierung, dass so eine technische Grundlage eben gibt. Web-Standards waren damals ja eigentlich erst richtig möglich mit der Browser- Generation, die so damals kam. Also so die fünfte, sechste Prinzip dann.
Die sogenannte fünfte Generation, ja. Die eigentlich eine zweite Generation war. Also die ersten, die sich mal für dich darum gekümmert haben, dass es Interoperabilität gab.
Ja, oder das eben CSS.
CSS, genau.
Das ist eigentlich der krasse Wechsel da. Also CSS macht eben auch viel möglich im Sinne von Datenintelligenz. Also dass die Daten zwar da sind, aber ihr Aussehen eben nicht. Die Daten selbst zerstört dabei. Also das, was Webdesigner jahrelang eben machen mussten, wo sie sich auch schuldig gemacht haben quasi. Also das Zerstören der Datenstruktur durch ihre visuelle Repräsentation.
Ja, das ist glaube ich eine unglaubliche, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Sucht sozusagen, dieses Medium so gestalten zu wollen, wie man das aus Print gewohnt war. Im Prinzip ist man heute noch nicht so richtig da.
Und naja, das war eben die Aufgabe des Webdesigners, war zu vermitteln zwischen dem Anspruch des Kunden quasi und auch des Betrachters, der eben nicht was komplett Neues so seltsam strukturiert ist eben wie ein HTML-Dokument, das ganz ungestylt da steht. Also was kann man eigentlich konsumieren quasi, als ungeübter Betrachter. Und da zu vermitteln, da haben die Webdesigner eben dann alles eingesetzt, was an Markup da war, was eben null semantisch dann angewendet wurde, also überhaupt nicht bezogen, für was es gedacht war. Tabellen-Layouts eben oder Blockquote ist so ein Beispiel. Das hat den Text eingerückt. Super, das nehmen wir jetzt, weil wir links mehr Platz wollen.
Genau, man ist so einfach von dieser Default-Erscheinung irgendwie ausgegangen, ohne wirklich dem semantischen Unterbau zu verstehen. Aber ist ja auch verständlich. Ich meine, woher soll es kommen? Ich denke, das war auch ein riesiger Lernprozess da auf beiden Seiten. Auf der einen Seite mussten die Designer erstmal verstehen, was HTML eigentlich ausdrücken wollte. Auf der anderen Seite mussten natürlich auch diejenigen, die diese Technologie bauen, erstmal verstehen, auf welche Ideen die anderen mittlerweile alle gekommen sind, wie man das halt auch noch benutzen könnte.
Na ja, und Gott sei Dank hat sich CSS eben soweit etabliert, dass wir das nicht mehr müssen, um die Gestaltung zu bestimmen, müssen wir nicht mehr die Daten kaputt machen. Und das wird natürlich dazu, dass die Daten sehr viel intelligenter bleiben und semantisch bleiben. Das war so ein Punkt, der dann eben so im Urzeigersinn so dazu führt, dass man die Daten wiederverwenden kann und dass man sie dann auch auf mobile Endgeräte bringen kann, dass Konvergenz möglich ist, also eigentlich echt das Multimedium noch dazukommt. Da kamen dann auch Podcasts auf und so in der Zeit. Das kommt halt alles zusammen. Und eben die große Partizipationsradikmenwechsel quasi oder die Stufe, die eigentlich die Grundidee darstellt. Das nämlich jeder jeder teilnimmt und sich gegenseitig Sachen zusendet und schreibt und sich verknüpft und sich Sachen empfiehlt.
Eigentlich ist es ja die Einlösung des alten Hackerversprechens, dass das Internet für alle da ist und dass jeder ein Sender sein kann. Brechts Radiotheorie, klopft da wieder an die Tür. Eigentlich ist es ja auch ein Ideal, den man da hinterher träumt. Und lange lange Zeit war es eigentlich nur dem Privilegierten offen. Entweder man musste viel Geld haben oder man musste besondere technische Fähigkeiten haben, um in irgendeiner Form da wirklich auch im Netz auf eine Art und Weise präsent zu sein, die jetzt auf gleicher Augenhöhe ist mit denen, die eben die Kohle haben.
Ja und jetzt kannst du eben Dienste nutzen, die quasi dir dieses technische Wissen abnehmen. Also du hast dann Blog-Software und kannst publizieren, also ein CMS, was irgendwie vor Jahren noch Millionen gekostet hat quasi. Und das hat jetzt jeder. Also es gibt natürlich immer noch so eine Schwelle, also die Schwelle des Installierens quasi, des Webspace-Habens. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Hosted Services irgendwie, wo du dich anmeldest und hast da nichts mit zu tun.
Und natürlich auch der Trend hin zu den sozialen Netzwerken, die sich in zunehmendem Maße als Internetportale präsentieren. Da werden wir sicherlich noch zu kommen. Aber ich finde hier gerade auch so die Orientierung an diesem Schaubild, was du da mal gemacht hast, ganz interessant. Was ja hier, also Web 2.0 prangt hier in der Mitte, schön gleich noch mit dem notorischen Beta. Was ja auch mittlerweile schon zu so einem eigenen Klassiker geworden ist, so dieses nie ist irgendetwas fertig. Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein wesentliches Merkmal der Zeit, dass eigentlich alles permanent im Fluss ist. Ich glaube sogar Google Mail ist immer noch Beta.
Ja, es gibt zumindest jetzt so...
Nicht mehr Beta, aber fast alles kommt heute raus als Beta. Man würde schon gar nicht mehr davon ausgehen, dass irgendetwas nicht als Beta erscheint.
Ja, das öffentliche Testen, das ist schon auch ein Bestandteil. Also Usability und auch Funktionalitäten und auch technisches... Also technisch wird kaum öffentlich getestet, aber welche Funktionen wollen die Nutzer wirklich von der Plattform? Also häufig passiert es ja auch, dass Plattformen echt so umgenutzt werden von Nutzern, weil das bestimmte Features einfach anders benutzt werden oder sehr viel stärker nachgefragt. Also das Einbinden der Nutzer schafft und auch von natürlich dann so Early Adoptern, die einfach auch schon viel anderes gesehen haben. Das ist für Dienst natürlich immer ein wichtiger Schritt, wo die dann auch lernen. Also meistens gibt es auch einen kompletten Relounge so nach so einer Phase.
Ja, weil man auch meistens gar nicht... Ich weiß nicht, ob du schon konkret was im Sinn hast. Mir fällt natürlich prompt dabei Twitter ein, die irgendwie auch auf eine Art und Weise gestartet sind, wo sie, glaube ich, eine gewisse Erwartungshaltung haben, was sie ihren Usern bieten, die das dann aber doch ganz anders genutzt haben. Also von dieser einfachen Status-Meldung hin richtig zu einem Diskussionsmedium.
Ja, also zumindest das, was auf der Plattform passiert. Also Twitter, wenn man es so sieht, als Instant-Messaging-Status-Meldung, also Instant-Message-Chat ist ja irgendwie immer noch eins zu eins oder eins zu ein paar Kommunikationen. Aber die Status-Meldung, die ich da eingeben kann, die ist dann an all meine Kontakte. Und dieses eine kleine Feature, wo ich irgendwie angeben kann, wo ich bin oder was ich mache oder irgendwie so, ob ich gerade gestört werden will oder nicht, das hat Twitter eben als Plattform ausgerollt sozusagen. Und man kann jetzt sich überlegen, was die Grundidee war von Twitter damals, bis es nur da irgendwie in den Geschichtsbüchern drin war.
Der Letzte, der es wusste, ist wahrscheinlich schon von einer halben Stunde gegangen.
Aber man kann sich vorstellen, dass es so als zentralisierter Ort, wo ich meinen Status abgebe und der dann irgendwie verteilt werden kann, gedacht ist, plus eben dieses SMS-Feature, also dass ich eine billige Variante habe, an viele Leute gleichzeitig eine SMS zu schicken auch. Das ist vielleicht auch noch so eine Grundidee.
Niemand weiß, wie die das bezahlen.
In Amerika zahlt der Empfänger einen Großteil der Gebühren, aus der Fähre ist es ein bisschen anders.
Aber die kommen ja auch in Deutschland an. Das ist ja schon normal.
Aber klar, da haben die Nutzer natürlich auch dann Features benutzt oder gebaut, also das Antworten auf eine Nachricht mit einem Adzeichen und Username. Das haben die Nutzer erfunden und erst später dann eingebaut, dass auch der Name dann verlinkt wird und der Bezugspunkt zum letzten.
Das heißt, die Ad-Notation in Twitter war zunächst einmal eine Konvention?
Na ja, eine Übereinkunft, die die Nutzer selbst erfunden haben.
Genau, also sie haben es einfach so eingeführt und dann wurde es so benutzt und man hat gesehen, das ist ja eine tolle Idee. Und dann kam später erst in Twitter die Funktionalität dazu, dass man das auch wirklich im System als eine Antwort versteht. Und prompt waren sie auf einmal ein Kommunikationsmedien.
Richtig, und man sieht auch, das funktioniert natürlich auch nicht gut, weil man kann ja nicht, man kann nur auf die letzte Antworten, man kann nicht auf die vorletzte Antworten, oder die sind dann nicht richtig korrekt verknüpft oder so. Und daran sieht man, dass das halt auch so eigentlich nicht gedacht war.
Aber ist das good enough?
Und das reicht auch aus. Aber interessant ist auch, was eben so eine offene Appie eben dann auch leistet und damals Flickr hat es damals auch perfekt gemacht, durch diese Offenheit auf die Daten zu gucken und die Daten zu nehmen und was Neues draus zu machen und zu verbinden mit damals die große Zeit der Mash-ups, was ja auch irgendwie vorbei ist. Aber damals eben, ich tu mal die Flickr-Bilder auf eine Karte drauf.
Die große Zeit der Mash-ups ist schon wieder vorbei?
Na ja, was gibt es noch, was nicht irgendwie zusammengeklumpt wurde?
Weiß nicht. Also du bist ja so ein bisschen, also wir hatten in dieser Chaosradio-Sende, die ich schon angesprochen habe, hatten wir dann irgendwann mal den schönen Begriff das Kosmar-Syndrom geprägt. Das Kosmar-Syndrom ist die Tatsache, dass wenn auch irgendwo ein Web 2.0-Dienst auf diesem Planeten aufmacht, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht länger als 30 Minuten dauert, bis es den Account Kosmar gibt. Wie viele Accounts hast du so im Web?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau.
Hast du eine Ahnung?
Nee, aber das ist schon mehr dreistellig, also mehrfach dreistellig irgendwie, sicher.
Mehrere hundert. Hast du die auch irgendwo? Ich meine, bist du noch in der Lage, dich in jeden einzelnen einzeln loggen?
Naja, ich habe so ein Schema, wie ich die Logins aufbaue. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich nicht ein Passwort überall habe, wie die meisten, sondern dass ich schon eigentlich überall das gleiche, also überall ein anderes habe.
Was aber sozusagen einem bestimmten Schema erfolgt, das weißt du nur du.
Ja, und da gibt es auch mehrere Eskalationsstufen an Wichtigkeit sozusagen und Komplexität des Passworts.
Kannst du da mal einen Tipp geben? Ich meine, das ist ja für viele Leute so ein bisschen so ein Problem, so diese Passwörter. Ich meine, ich bin da ganz faul, ich lasse mir einfach jedes Passwort immer wieder neu generieren und baller das halt in so eine Key-Chain. Aber wenn ich halt mal ohne meinen eigenen Laptop rumlatsche, dann bin ich natürlich verloren.
Ja, also solche Password-Manager, also One Password oder was es da gibt.
So was zum Beispiel, genau, auf dem Mac gibt es ja sicher mäßig diese Schlüsselblutfunktion, da kann man es ja schon reinballern. Solche speziellen Tools machen es einem dann ein bisschen einfacher. Mehrere Accounts pro Dienst dann noch mal zu unterscheiden. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie drei verschiedene Google-Accounts braucht, das gehört ja heute schon zum guten Ton.
Na ja, also man muss das natürlich aus dem Namen des Dienstes irgendwie generieren. Man nimmt da irgendwelche, den dritten Buchstaben verschiebt in zwei Stellen im Alphabet und so. Und hat dann noch so einen statischen Teil. Und dann noch ein paar Sonderzeichen links und rechts. Also kann man sich schon was machen. Aber die Lösung ist das alles nicht. OpenID ist da schon ein viel besserer Ansatz.
Genau, ein technischer Punkt, auf den wir sicherlich gleich nochmal zu sprechen kommen. Ich verschiebe immer ungern Dinge nach hinten. Aber was ich auf jeden Fall vorher noch mal so hinterfragt haben wollte, du bist ja nun eine dieser sichtbareren oder öffentlicheren Personen in diesem neuen Web. Einerseits, weil du halt wie so ein bunter Hund überall deinen Account hast, aber auch weil du eben auch viele Dienste ja auch aktiv benutzt. Und da stelle ich dir jetzt zumindest mal. Wie sieht denn so ein Tag im Leben des Kosmar aus?
Naja, das wechselt natürlich auch so zeitweise. Ich benutze natürlich eigentlich schon immer und gerne StumbleUpon als Bookmarking-Dienst. Also Social Bookmarks waren ja auch echt ein ganz früheres Bereich von Web 2.0, wo man auch Empfehlungen sieht, dass die in einem großen Baustein davon sind, empfehlen und selbst publizieren, sich selbst sammeln und sich selbst darstellen dadurch natürlich. Da habe ich früher angefangen, nicht Delish zu benutzen, sondern StumbleUpon zu benutzen, was so ein bisschen mehr Funktionen hat, wo du eben auch Empfehlungen aktiv bekommst. Du musst nur auf den Knopf drücken, du kriegst eine neue Website, die zu dem passt, was du mochtest. Das benutze ich immer noch dafür. Und dann Twitter benutze ich, um ein bisschen ein Tagebuch zu schreiben quasi, also Tag im Sinne von dann auch schon stundenweise.
Das Internet-Tagebuch, da ist es wieder.
Also Microplogging, so nennt man das ja eigentlich. Und es ist halt interessant, wie viel man in so einem kurzen 140 Zeichen erlaubten Feld dann noch ausdrücken kann. Und natürlich gibt es auch Missverständnisse. Aber trotzdem, wenn ich so zurückplättere, das ist jetzt ein Jahr her, oder seit ich ein bisschen mehr, anderthalb Jahre, kann ich mich schon erinnern. Also es hat schon so eine Tagebuchfunktion.
Das machst du auch. Das heißt du sonntags, nach dem Frühstück blätterst du in den alten Zeiten.
Kann man machen.
Damals vor drei Monaten.
Also oft schmeißt man da auch Links rein, die man empfiehlt. Und das übernimmt auch manchmal Social Bookmarking schon wieder. Und da es schon relativ gut durchsuchbar ist, nicht bei Twitter selbst. Also mittlerweile haben sie diese Suchmaschine da aufgekauft. Da kann man schon ganz gut suchen. Aber selbst Google indiziert das großartig. Also wenn man nicht den Stream protektet, dann kann man da schon alles wiederfinden. Das ist schon so. Ja, so was. Flickr benutzt sie nicht mehr, aber ich habe Ipernity als Bilderdienst.
Ipernity.
So ein französischer Startup.
Flickr benutzt sie warum nicht mehr?
Na ja, damals durch die deutsche Version gab es dann so ein kleines Problem, das manche Zensur genannt haben. Also der Jugendschutz in Deutschland wurde ein bisschen überinterpretiert von Yahoo. Und sie waren gleichzeitig eben zu bequem, eine vernünftige Altersabfrage zu machen für die Nutzer. Und dadurch kann eigentlich kein Deutscher alle Bilder sehen. Also es gibt da so mehrere Stufen.
Das ist also ein Problem, was nur in Deutschland existiert?
Nee, auch in Singapur, Hongkong und Korea.
Generell geht man sozusagen dazu, über sich auch an die Gesetze zu halten.
Ja klar, wobei das, naja, da machen es die Chinesen von sich aus. Aber Yahoo macht es eben so. In Deutschland, man weiß es nicht genau, weil zwischen Deutschland und Belgien ist jetzt nicht so der große Unterschied auch in Europa. Also wie auch immer die darauf kommen, dass der Jugendschutz hier wirklich schlimmer wäre als in unseren Nachbarländern. Aber die haben das damals gemacht und da habe ich dann gewechselt und habe das damals sehr intensiv benutzt. Flickr hat natürlich auch für mich als Designer viele Features gebracht, die interessant sind, gerade jetzt so Conversational Design, auch Patterns, also dieses Annotieren von Bildern, also Tagging eben sehr intensiv und auch im Bild selbst was markieren und gleichzeitig ein soziales Netz zu sein und gleichzeitig so ein Live-Aspekt zu haben.
Jetzt haben wir, genau, jetzt kommen wir auch schon so langsam so ein bisschen auf die Spur. Ich meine, es gibt da eine ganze Menge Dinge, die man jetzt genauer betrachten könnte, aber ich fände es ganz wertvoll, wenn wir so ein bisschen auch nochmal aufblättern, was eigentlich so der Nutzungskatalog ist, der sich so entfaltet, den das Web 2.0 so mit sich gebracht hat. Du hast ja jetzt auch schon so ein paar Sites genannt, die du selber benutzt. Wer waren denn so die ersten, die man jetzt eigentlich wirklich als Dienst benennen kann, die so diesen Web 2.0-Stempel auch wirklich verdient haben? Es gibt da verschiedene Kategorien, die man jetzt unterscheiden muss. Vielleicht steigen wir mal kurz ein, du hast gesagt, du hast Delicious relativ früh benutzt. Das ist ja ein sogenanntes Social Bookmarking. Die haben, glaube ich, auch diesen Begriff ursprünglich mal geprägt.
Die haben zuerst ein Social Bookmarking geprägt, ein bisschen. Da gibt es auch echt sehr viele Konkurrenten natürlich dann. Und die haben auch dieses Tagging eben als Grundlage eingeführt. Das Dumbledore-Pon gibt es vielleicht schon ein bisschen länger. Die hatten aber keine Texte, weil das war damals noch nicht so üblich. Texte an sich, also Schlüsselworte an Objekte hängen, das gibt es so in Bibliothekenwesen und solchen Zirkeln gibt es quasi schon ewig. Aber dass das nur zur Selbstmachung, Fuxonami hieß es damals, der Begriff wird halt auch nicht mehr so geläufig sein.
Oh ja, Stimmt, Fuxonami sozusagen. Eine Kategorisierung, die nicht eben durch einen vorgefertigten Kategorie- Katalog gemacht wird, sondern man kann sich zu jedem Objekt, in dem Fall sind es halt einfach URLs, einfach irgendwelche Begriffe ausdenken, die natürlich am Anfang vor allem englische Worte waren. Da eignet sich natürlich auch die englische Sprache mal wieder wunderbar mit ihren kurzen Worten und vor allem mit ihren ganzen Gummivorten. Man kann dann einfach mehrere von diesen Gummivorten da drauf werfen und daraus ergeben sich dann, naja, Suchmuster, sodass man eben so eine Sache... Dann kam diese Tech-Cloud auf. Ich glaube, das war auch schon so ein Ergebnis von Delicious. Also diese Tags haben sich einfach, das fand ich in vieler Hinsicht interessant, weil erstens funktionieren sie besser als vorgegebene Kategorien, weil sonst müsste man ja Millionen vorgeben, aus denen man sich dann welche aussucht, sondern bei Delicious basierte das einfach darauf, dass die Leute sich einfach selber was ausgedacht haben und dann stellte man fest, eigentlich kommen sowieso alle mehr oder weniger auf die gleichen Ideen.
Nur wusste man vorher nicht, welche Ideen es sind.
Genau.
Ja, also das hat natürlich auch einen Echo-Effekt. Also Tags sind auch ein Pattern, wenn man so will, und auch das Tagging an sich, also auch die Wolke. Also man macht es erstmal für sich selbst, um Sachen für sich selbst zu verschlagworten und wiederzufinden, ob das jetzt Bilder sind oder URLs. Und wenn mehrere Leute es für sich selbst machen, mit den gleichen Daten, also URLs, die eben da sind, Webseiten, dann bilden sich eben Worte, die öfter angehängt werden an einen Begriff. Und das ist dann eben größer in der Wolke für diesen einen Begriff. Und dann gibt's wieder alle Objekte, und dann gibt's wieder Objekte, die sich einen Begriff teilen, dann gehören die wieder in eine Schublade. Und so wächst so eine globale Wolke. Es gibt immer diese private Ansicht, die persönliche Ansicht, und immer die globale Ansicht immer auf ein Objekt oder auf alle Objekte. So kann man Tagging eigentlich sehen. Aber die Tag Wolke an sich, so eine Begriffwolke, die wurde zu so einem Markenzeichen von solchen Diensten, dass die häufig auch ohne Verstand eingesetzt wurde dann später. Also man muss sich ja vorstellen, die macht nur Sinn, wenn sie alphabetisch ist zum Beispiel. So eine Tag Wolke. Ja, die muss alphabetisch sein. Warum? Sortiert? Ja, die Sortierung ist ja die, also die Häufigkeit ist die Größe. Und die Sortierung ist, das soll ja zur Recherche dienen. Also ich will einen Begriff suchen und gucken, wie häufig der ist oder so. Oder ich will schneller sehen, wer häufig ist. Aber ich muss dann eine zweite Sortierungsebene, wie sie eben in der Reihenfolge dargestellt ist, und da sollte sie eben alphabetisch sein. Man kann ja auch Zeit nehmen als Sortierung dafür. Aber so klassischerweise ist es eben so. Und die Größe ist die Menge oder die Popularität über eine gewisse Zeit kann man auch, je nachdem, wie es eingesetzt ist.
Auf jeden Fall ist es so eine zweidimensionale Geschichte, wo die Popularität immer mit drin ist.
Genau. Aber das wurde dann von manchen Diensten einfach irgendwie, die Reihenfolge war egal und bla. Also da sieht man, dass das eben eigentlich mehr so ein visuelles Markenzeichen schon wurde. Und auch heutzutage nicht mehr so die Grundlage ist, nicht mehr Foxonomy und Tag, sondern es wird noch intelligenter dann, wenn es überhaupt gemacht wird, wird dann übers Verhalten schon werden Sachen gewichtet.
Wessen Verhalten?
Und der Nutzer. Also Tags dienen natürlich auch dazu, dir was zu empfehlen. Also du suchst was und guckst danach und schlägst danach und was ist groß und von meinen Freunden benutzen, die alle dieses Wort oder beschäftigen sich gerade alle damit und dann gucke ich da rein. Und das kann man aber auch implizit machen, dass dir das dann schon geliefert wird, so das Objekt selbst. Bei Musik zum Beispiel, so Last FM war ja auch ein Dienst, den es schon relativ lang gibt. Da gibt es ja auch Tags, aber Musik ist auch so ganz schwer zu verschlagworten und deswegen macht das auch kaum jemand. Aber das implizite Verhalten halt, ich hab das gehört und ich schick dir das explizit oder viele Leute haben ähnliches gehört und dann baue ich im automatischen Radio auf für den Nutzer. Aus seinen Nachbarschaften, seinen geschmacklichen Nachbarschaften dann ein individuelles Musikstream zusammenstellen für dich. Da brauchst du die Tags dann quasi nicht mehr, sondern nur noch das Verhalten.
Diese Delicious gibt es ja immer noch, hat für meine Wahrnehmung nicht mehr so ganz die überbordende Bedeutung wie am Anfang, was natürlich auch in der Konkurrenz vieler anderer Systeme liegt. Aber hast du den Eindruck, dass das noch eine Rolle spielt?
Na ja, Yahoo hat das ja schon länger gekauft und es gab jetzt vor ganz kurzem einen Relaunch davon, der ganz interessant ist.
Genau, die sind jetzt auch nicht mehr unter dieser geilen Domain, mit der sie ursprünglich gestartet sind.
Ja, sind sie auch noch, aber delicious.com ist jetzt auch.
Das ist vielleicht einfacher einzugeben, aber das muss man gleich nochmal sagen. Also delicious startete, ich glaube, der erste Dienst, der sich wirklich mal getraut hat, die US-Domain zu verwenden, die ja ansonsten ziemlich verpönt ist in den USA, weil es irgendwie ihnen das Gefühl gibt, so zu sein wie alle anderen. dell.ico.us, jetzt sind sie halt delicious.com. Dann gab es eine ganze Menge Kloner, auch hier in Deutschland. Mr. Wong ist so eine ähnliche Projektierung. Und dann kam, ja, StumbleUpon hast du schon genannt, das gab es schon vorher.
Gibt es schon seit 1993, 1994.
Da bin ich dann später erst drüber gestoßen, sozusagen, drüber gestumpled. Aber dann gab es ja so eine kleine Revolution mit dem Service DIG.
Ja, wobei das eben nur ein kleiner anderer Aspekt ist.
Da ging es aber auch um URLs.
Da ging es auch um URLs.
Aber es ging vor allem um Nachrichten.
Vor allem ums Empfehlen und um Nachrichten. Also um Tech-News quasi. Also Slashdot, so als Vorläufer damals gesehen. Und DIG eben ein bisschen schneller. Man kann eine URL da reinschmeißen, ein bisschen kommentieren.
Ja, vor allem bei Slashdot war halt alles irgendwie erstmal auf Slashdot. Und bei DIG ging es eigentlich von vornherein immer schon darum, die Leute auf andere Sites zu schicken. Das heißt, DIG selber hat nicht die News gebracht, sondern DIG hat nur den Link auf die News gebracht.
Also es gibt natürlich so ein Feld, wo man dann sagen kann, warum das jetzt irgendwie wichtig ist und warum ich das empfehle. Und es geht bei DIG auch weniger ums Bookmarken als ums wirklich Verbreiten. Also man benutzt den DIG-Account jetzt nicht dazu, Sachen sich zu merken unbedingt. Also so wie es angelegt ist. Sondern mehr darum, hier das finde ich auch wichtig. Oder also da geht, ist ja auch so ein System, wo es im System selbst kocht. Also jemand schmeißt dir zwar rein die Sachen, aber man klickt dann da, ich auch, ich auch, ich auch, finde es auch toll. Und das ist auch eine Art von Selbstdarstellung, was man alles toll findet. Und plus irgendwie, ich habe es auch noch gefunden, krass. Und ich kommentiere jetzt auch noch was Blödes dazu.
Ist das so die Hauptmotivation?
Na, bei Dick ist es schon, also, man kann viel lesen über, wie ist ein Dick-User eigentlich im Kopf. Also, weil es gibt natürlich Leute, die da ständig davor sitzen oder saßen zumindest, ein bisschen abgenommen wahrscheinlich. Und die haben sich natürlich auch verbreitert, haben mehr Themenfelder jetzt aufgenommen und so. Und haben jetzt auch neuerdings ganz neu so eine Empfehlungsmaschine dann, die auch wirklich eher guckt auf die Vergangenheit, was man schon gedickt hat. Und man hat ja da auch ein Netzwerk von Quellen.
So wie Amazon ein Produkt vorschlägt, wird einem auch News vorgeschlagen.
Und wie StumbleUpon eben auch funktioniert, dass es eben auf der Vergangenheit basierende und auf dem Netzwerk basierende Vorschläge gibt.
Ist das da, wo eigentlich alle hinwollen?
Also die Nutzer? Ich glaube, viel davon tatsächlich ist diese Empfehlungsmaschine. Recommendation ist schon so ein Bedarf quasi. Also so wie es irgendwie oh, es gibt keine Musiksender mehr. Und Bravo lese ich jetzt auch nicht mehr und so. Also es gibt halt...
Radio höre ich auch nicht.
Ja, und Radio ist zu breit irgendwie. Also es kommt da auch immer nur dasselbe. Also es gibt nichts mehr, was irgendwie die Generation 30 Jahre irgendwie als Autorität hat für Musik zum Beispiel. Also nehme ich mich eben selbst als Autorität und die Freunde, die ich so habe oder suche mir neue Freunde, die mir empfohlen werden durch das System oder wo ich eben feststelle, die sind so ähnlich wie ich und hole mir da meine Empfehlungen, was jetzt toll ist und gut ist und lese irgendwie MP3-Blogs oder und höre mir eben Last FM an und es ist dann das Radio, das ich selbst quasi mache durch meinen Geschmack und meine Vergangenheit und mein explizites Mögen von Dingen und so. Und das kann man immer übertragen, so auch auf eben was Amazon zum Beispiel macht. Ist ja auch so die Recommendation in reinen Form. Also die tracken ja alles sozusagen mit. Wenn man Link anguckt bei Amazon, dann hat der immer so einen Hash hinten dran, wo dann kodiert ist, wo genau der Link ist und du klickst da auf den dritten Link in der Box da und da, um auch das System selbst zu optimieren. Und das wird dann gewertet als deine Historie von Interesse. Also wenn du da in dem Teaserbox geklickt hast, hat das einen anderen Stellenwert als wenn du das Produkt irgendwie anders gefunden hast oder über eine Suche und so weiter und so weiter. Und wenn man da sehr fein ausdifferenziert, kann man sehr gut das Empfehlungssystem eben machen. Und da steckt in vielen Diensten eben auch noch Potenzial, diese Empfehlungen noch besser zu machen und Sachen noch zu gewichten. Also wenn ich kommentiert habe, ist es mir wirklich sehr wichtig. Und wenn ich es nur angeguckt habe, ist es vielleicht relativ unwichtig. So weiter.
Man gewinnt den Eindruck, dass es immer vor allem auch um das Individuum geht. So der Einzelne steht auf einmal total im Mittelpunkt.
Na ich selbst zumindest mal. Und du natürlich auch, weil du wie ich quasi dann da drin bist und dich darstellst mit dem, was du getan hast, was du gedacht hast, was du fotografiert hast oder so. Und häufig ein guter Dienst macht eben auch das Liefern von eigenen Daten dazu führt, dass ich gute Empfehlungen bekomme oder dass ich natürlich einmal gut dastehe, also Reputation und Selbstdarstellung und Eitelkeit und so was ist natürlich schon wichtig. Aber wenn es noch einen zweiten Nutzen gibt, dass ich dadurch eben auch Menschen auf mich zukommen und ich irgendwie sozialen Kontakt tatsächlich habe oder dass mir eben in diesem Social Object fällt, also wenn es jetzt Musik ist oder Bücher oder gibt es ja für alles sozusagen Netzwerke, dass ich da eben auch noch gute Empfehlungen bekomme für meine persönliche Zukunft. Wenn das zusammenkommt alles, dann ist es natürlich sehr schön.
Du hast da eben schon Last FM genannt, vielleicht wollen wir das auch nochmal kurz erläutern für diejenigen, die das nicht kennen. Was macht Last FM?
Also es sendet das, was ich in iTunes und es unterstützt auch noch mehr andere Player, aber was ich an Musikplayer da höre, den Titel selbst, das schickt es in eine Liste auf den Server und da kann ich dann sehen, meine Charts, also ich habe am meisten gehört dies und das, und aber auch kann ich da Freunde haben, natürlich.
Was heißt es sendet das, sendet das wirklich die Musik hoch?
Nee, nur die Information, welcher Titel es ist. Also nur quasi ein Abdruck von, ich habe dieses Lied gehört, nicht die Datei selbst.
Damit hört man ja dann sozusagen noch nichts.
Damit hört man erstmal noch nichts. Aber so die Rückseite von Last FM ist dann das Radio, wo ich mir eine Applikation installiere, mit der ich dann Empfehlungen quasi geliefert bekomme, aufgrund meines Geschmacks in der Vergangenheit oder meines Netzwerks, klar beides. Und ich kann da aber auch filtern nach, mehr davon oder ein gewisser Tag oder eine gewisse Richtung zu hören. Und die Musik, die kommt dann aus einer anderen Quelle. Also Last FM ist auch von, wie gehört das jetzt, CBS, glaube ich, hat das gekauft, wo man sich dann eben auch fragen muss, will man seine Hörgewohnheiten quasi an, doch eine größere Firma dann ficken als Konsument, Freihaus, die stehen da jetzt dahinter. Aber es gibt da auch Konkurrenten, also Pandora kann man jetzt aus rechtlichen Gründen in Europa nicht mehr so richtig ganz legal hören.
Was hat das gemacht?
Na, da geht es eben um Lizenzrechte.
Also Pandora streamt einfach?
Pandora schickt auch so ein Ähnlichkeitsradio, da suche ich mir ein Lied aus und es schickt dann oder sendet dann eben ähnliches hinterher, passendes. Also ich hab jetzt Bock auf David Bowie und dann kommen eben Placebo als zweites. So ungefähr. Da gibt es auch einige andere Feintune und so, die das auch ganz gut machen. Das ist dann eben ganz unterhaltsam, aber so rechtlich, lizenzrechtlich ist es natürlich in manchen Ländern, wie auch unserem, dann eben eher schwierig. Deswegen haben die das so eingeschränkt, dass man das nur in den USA eigentlich benutzen kann. Dann gibt es noch iLike. Die senden gar nicht, sondern das ist dann so ein reines Social Network unten auf Listen. iLike ist auch sehr beliebt, eigentlich deshalb, weil es auf Facebook schneller war als Last FM. Also mit iLike kann man auf Facebook sich gegenseitig Lieder dedikaten und ich kann dir ein Lied als Gruß schicken, quasi. Solche Sachen. Und da waren die einfach viel schneller als Last FM damals. Und sind auch wahrscheinlich immer noch so die beliebteste Applikation innerhalb von Facebook.
Da kommen wir ja jetzt sozusagen in den Bereich rein, der, glaube ich, so umstritten ist wie eigentlich schon lange nichts mehr in der letzten Zeit. Die Social Network Sites, die, die einen mit weiten Armen mit all seinen Profildaten aufnehmen. Da gibt es ja gleich mehrere, die sich so die Welt derzeit aufteilen. Also hier in Deutschland, denke ich mal, sind es vor allem zwei. Da gibt es so die Business-Welt. Das ist Xing, former als OpenBC, die es geschafft haben, glaube ich, jeden halbwegs Gewerbetreibenden mittlerweile mit seiner Visitenkarte aufzunehmen. Dann noch sehr viel umstrittener, allein schon wegen ihrer ursprünglichen Zielgruppe. Studi- und Schülerfortset als, glaube ich, das am meisten verbreitete soziale Netzwerk für Jugendliche. Das ist das, was hier in Deutschland groß ist. International, schon ein paar Mal haben wir es erwähnt, ist Facebook. Was müsste man sonst noch erwähnen?
Es gibt in Deutschland schon noch auch regional aktive Sachen. Lokalisten gibt es zum Beispiel in München hauptsächlich. Oder dann noch für noch kleinere Kinder. Gibt es auch schon einiges.
Noch kleinere Kinder? Was ist das für eine Krabbelgruppe?
Knuddelst ist super beliebt.
Ach, habe ich auch schon mal gehört.
Oder Quick gibt es auch noch. Das ist dann aber auch schon für Jugendliche. Aber das ist so regionale Sache. Wer kennt wen? Gibt es noch sowas?
Regional, wie meinst du das regional? Nordrhein-Westfalen oder was?
Ja, so Baden-Württemberg quasi. Oder so Bundesländer, fast schon auf Stadt-Ebene. Lokalisten gibt es echt nur in großen Städten. Und da ist auch der Münchner Raum, glaube ich, so das Größte, was die haben. Aber da sind in so einer kleinen Sparte die dann auch schon sehr erfolgreich.
Spielt das denn eine große Rolle, dieser regionale Bezug?
Na ja, es ist immer so die Frage, wie ist das Mapping von echtem Sozial-, also echt im Sinne von Riechen, sozialem Umfeld und elektrisch. Also sind meine Kontakte in meinem Social-Network-Sing irgendwie, habe ich die alle schon mal getroffen. Also da ist es schon eher wahrscheinlich.
Das macht aber jeder anders, oder? Es gibt Leute, was weiß ich hier, Joyito hat glaube ich so die halbe Welt auf seinen Freundeslisten, nur damit er irgendwie der erste ist, der die Systemgrenzen sprengt. Andere Leute wählen da sehr viel feiner aus, aber da gibt es ja nichts etabliertes, von daher kann man gar keine Erwartungshaltung haben an diese Netze, oder?
Das kann tatsächlich jeder selbst skalieren. Man veröffentlicht da ja auch Daten, jetzt nicht nur an den Betreiber, sondern eben auch an die Kontakte. Häufig können ja die Kontakte mehr sehen als jeder Ex-Beliebige oder Google. Und die kriegen größeren Einblick in meine privatsphäre. Das muss dann jeder selbst sozusagen austarieren, wen er da rein nimmt, aktiv oder auch zulässt. Man kann sich auch oft Einstellungen machen, was wer sehen kann. Also bei Xing zum Beispiel kann man einstellen, dass nur Kontakte der Kontakte dann wiederum meine Kontaktliste sehen können und nicht alle. Oder Google darf mein Profil nicht sehen und so. Häufig kann man so was einstellen. Aber auch tatsächlich ja eben durch das Zufügen, wen füge ich da hinzu. Aber oft ist es natürlich so, dass man nicht den wirklichen Freundeskreis, bekannten Kreis da drin hat, was man jetzt so früher angesehen hätte als eben das ist mein soziales Umfeld. Davon sind einfach, dafür ist es noch nicht mainstream genug. Also Studiefort ist vielleicht schon der Sprung in den Mainstream, wo tatsächlich mehr Mitglieder in der Plattform sind, als es Studenten gibt. Also da kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich so mein ganzer Kurs da irgendwie schon drin ist. Da ist es schon anders, also das ist aber dann wieder eingegrenzt auf meine im Prinzip Arbeitsebene, wenn man es als Student sieht. Da muss man jetzt schon Glück haben, wenn der Rest der Freunde schon mit drin sind. Da gibt es immer eine Diskrepanz halt. Und wenn die aber lokal aktiv sind, auch nur ein bisschen, dann ist es ja schon wieder was anderes. Dann habe ich auch die Chance, die dann zu treffen, die ich dort über die Plattform kennenlerne und so einen anderen Aspekt. Das entwickelt sich aber auch aus dem, entweder ist es angelegt im Produkt, dass es lokal funktionieren soll oder es ist eben global gleich angelegt. Die Sprache hat da eben auch häufig einen Einfluss. Also Facebook, die deutsche Version ist jetzt nicht so dolle, dass sie irgendwie Studie-Vorzeit überrennen sollte. Aber das Potenzial wäre natürlich da von der Funktionalität her. Und wenn es noch nicht so eine etablierte Plattform gäbe, könnten die da schon was machen, aber das dem ist nicht so.
Jetzt sind ja, also ich hab's ja schon angedeutet, die Social Networks sind einfach extrem umstritten und verschrien. Das geht wahrscheinlich im Besonderen auch noch an den Kernzuhörerkreis von Chaosradio Express. So die technisch geprägte Hacker-Szene oder sagen wir mal auch, wo viele Leute ja auch drin sind, die einerseits schon sehr lange dabei sind, andererseits auch eine besonders intensive Herangehensweise haben, um am Netz teilzunehmen. Ich kann natürlich immer vieles nicht so richtig verstehen, aber ich hab selber mal versucht, so ein bisschen mehr darüber Gedanken zu machen, was eigentlich der Reiz ist, also was wirklich der Antrieb ist. Weil letztlich, man macht ja nichts, was einem nicht irgendetwas bringt. Ich meine, da gibt es kurzfristige Erwartungshaltungen, die sich dann erfüllen oder nicht erfüllen, aber diese ganzen Dienste sind jetzt eigentlich schon viel zu lange am Start, als dass es nur davon leben könnte. Also sicherlich gibt es da eine permanente Verpuffung von Leuten, die da einfach gar nicht das gefunden haben, was drin ist. Ich hab auch mal mit jungen Schülern gesprochen, die meinten so, naja, Studi-VZ und so, da musste ja drin sein. Ich so, ja wieso musste da drin sein? Die anderen sind ja auch alle da. Also einfach dieser Gruppenklickendruck, da kann man sich das gar nicht erlauben, das nicht zumindest auch ausprobiert zu haben, allein weil man so die Pausenhof-Schelte da nicht mehr tragen könnte. Ach guck mal, der hat ja noch nicht mal ein Profil bei Studi-VZ, wer ist der denn? Ganz klar. Aber auch das wird natürlich nicht lange verfangen. Es würde mich mal auch mal interessieren, was so dein Blickwinkel auf den realen Nutzen dieser Dienste ist. Eine Sache vielleicht vorweg. Du kannst ja mal sagen, ob du das genau so siehst oder nicht. Was meinen Aha-Effekte war, ist der, dass diese Systeme, Facebook im Übrigen noch mehr als alle anderen, so von meiner eigenen Erfahrung, aber ich hänge nur wirklich nicht in allen diesen Netzwerken rum, dass sie sich eigentlich in zunehmendem Maße so wie das kleine Internet gebärden, dass man dort einfach sich einloggt und dann hat man dort einfach alles und man kann an allem über ein einziges Interface teilnehmen und es ist auf einmal einfach.
Also bei Facebook stimmt das wahrscheinlich schon mehr als bei den anderen. Xing hat jetzt nicht so eine Funktionalität, dass es wirklich irgendwie als Ersatz für Web-Erfahrung quasi dienen könnte.
Aber viele Leute schicken einem Nachrichten zum Beispiel, anstatt dass sie mir selber eine E-Mail schicken.
E-Mail ist natürlich schon so eine Sache. Also das ist durchaus schon auch dem normalen Nutzer irgendwie bewusst, dass E-Mail durch Spam irgendwie ein bisschen komisch geworden ist. Und man kann sich eben wirklich nicht sicher sein, dass eine E-Mail ankommt. Wenn ich dir jetzt eine E-Mail schick, wenn ich die noch gar nicht kenne außerdem.
Ich hab dir doch eine Mail geschickt, ach die war in meinem Spam-Filter.
Ja, erstens das und zweitens, wenn wir uns noch gar nicht kennen und noch gar nicht gemailt haben, dann ist es so noch unsicherer im Gefühl. Und wenn ich dir aber auf Xing irgendwie eine Nachricht schicken darf oder so, dann ist ja schon so ein Trust aufgebaut über die Plattform an sich. Und es ist irgendwie schon gesicherter, dass ich die irgendwie kriege.
Und man weiß auch, in welchem Kontext es ist.
Also, was du vorhin gesagt hast, dieser Gruppendruck, der ist natürlich auch da. Auch bei Xing ist es genau das gleiche Spiel wie auf einem Campus. Das ist dann irgendwie eine Konferenz oder irgendein beruflicher Zusammenhang, wo du Leute, Visitenkarten irgendwie austauschst und dann, wenn ich nach Hause komme, dann liegen da die 20 Karten und die gucke ich erstmal auf Xing durch. Auch so ein Pattern ist so dieses Freund eines Freundes, Friend of a Friend oder Six Decrees, so diese Systematik, dass ich eben sehen kann, wie viel Schritten jemand mit mir verbunden ist.
Six Decrees, diese alte These, das alle wie mit einem...
Hab ich schon wieder gelesen, auch schon wieder nachgewiesen.
Aber es sind eher 7 als 6.
6,5, 6,6. Instant Messaging wurde da als Grundlage benutzt.
Richtig, genau, das war Microsoft. Die Forschungsabteilung hat ihren, auch ein interessantes Detail, haben ihren kompletten, ich glaube, die haben wirklich den kompletten, aber angeblich anonymisierten Instant Messaging-Traffic, also der nur über MSN geht, ausgewertet und dabei sind sie, glaube ich, auf 6,8 oder so.
Und das ist natürlich was, was ich in einem normalen Gespräch nicht darstellen kann. Also wenn ich jetzt jemanden treffe auf einer Konferenz und wir reden, wir tauschen, wie sieht es aus? Dann haben wir ja nicht die Zeit, all unsere Bekannten zu vergleichen und schon gar nicht auf dritter Ebene, weil wir es gar nicht können. Also ich kann jetzt nicht die Bekannten meiner Bekannten kennen, sonst würde ich sie ja kennen. Und das kann aber das System eben liefern. Also wenn da zwei Stufen dazwischen sind, dann könnten wir das persönlich gar nicht ermitteln.
Und was liefert dir das? Also liefert dir das ein gewisses Vertrauen?
Ja, das liefert mir so eine Einschätzung zumindest. Also ich hab natürlich auch Kontakte in Xing, die haben ja alle so ihr Bild in mir. Also da ist das Vertrauen mehr oder weniger. Und auch das, naja, würde ich seinen Bekannten wiederum vertrauen. Und das liefert dann schon eine Einschätzung von einer dritten Person. Die ist natürlich auch Quatsch letztlich. Also das ist ein Konstrukt im Kopf und bietet vielleicht höchstens so einen Anstoß für die nächste Kommunikation irgendwie. Wenn es wirklich interessant ist für mich beruflich oder so. Oder dass mich jemand empfiehlt. Jemand oder wir kennen uns ja auch, du kennst ja auch den und so. Das geht schon. Und gibt dann aber auch so ein soziales Abwehr, also ein Vertrauensvorsprung oder irgendeine Einschätzung. Das kann ja auch negativ sein. Aber die trügt wahrscheinlich. Aber sie ist zumindest eine. Besser als nichts. Und letztlich ist ja auch Google nichts anderes. Also nur unter Dokumenten. Die haben eine Beziehung zueinander, haben aufeinander verlinkt und empfehlen sich quasi gegenseitig. Und ich erkenne irgendwelche Absender oder irgendwelche Seiten in einem Google-Suchergebnis und traue dann etwas. Google ist ja auch nur ein Netzwerk mit Empfehlungen und Verknüpfungen von Dokumenten. Und so ist es mit Menschen natürlich auch abbildbar. Und dieses Ganze wurde von vielen empfohlen, kennt viele Leute und das funktioniert in Relevanz bei Dokumenten bei Google und funktioniert bei Menschen eben auch auf eine Art. Und gleichzeitig auch dieses Umkippen, wenn jemand ganz viele, über 1000 Kontakte hat, gibt es ja auch so um, dass der entweder ist es sein Beruf, viele Leute zu kennen.
Es gibt um, was gibt um?
Naja, du hast dann das Gefühl, wenn dich jemand aufnimmt in seinen Kontaktliste, der aber auch schon 3000 kennt, dann hat es keinen Wert mehr. Also dann ist es ja auch Quatsch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und häufig, also es kommt auch vor, dass ich solche Sachen dann ablehne oder wieder auflöse, weil es eben auch dieses 6 degrees versaut. Also wenn der alle kennt, dann habe ich mit allen plötzlich eine Beziehung von nur einer Stufe. Und dann wird dieses Pattern für mich auch wertlos. Weil dann kenne ich ihn über dich und mir wird immer nur der kürzeste Weg angezeigt.
Eigentlich bräuchte man ein Netzwerk, wo man beweisen muss, dass man die anderen auch kennt.
Naja, das war bei LinkedIn lange Zeit so. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen aufweichter.
LinkedIn ist ein aus dem Business orientiertes soziales Netzwerk, was vor allem in Nordamerika groß ist. Ist das da das Größte eigentlich? Ist das so das Singen der USA und Kanada?
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Da gibt es aber auch noch Rise, glaube ich.
Ja, gibt noch so ein paar.
Okay, aber LinkedIn ist die Nummer 1, okay.
Und da gab es zum Beispiel lange keine Bilder von Personen. Ja, haben sie aber jetzt auch. Und lange musste man auch eine E-Mail-Adresse kennen.
Ah ja, okay, dann muss man schon wirklich ganz gut beweisen. Man kann nicht einfach mal so anklicken.
Genau, das ist auch das Schöne, was du vorhin meintest, dass man Nachrichten eher über Sing schickt als über E-Mail. Das ist ja genau dieses doppelte Erlauben. Also ich kenn dich, du kennst mich, und jetzt können wir kommunizieren, was bei E-Mail eben nicht da ist. Jeder kann mir eher eine Mail schicken. Und im Prinzip kann mich auch jeder anrufen, aber er muss die Nummer kennen und so. Also da ist es ja auch schon so ein bisschen doppeltes Opt-in quasi. Ich geb dir meine Nummer, wenn du mich anrufst, dann seh ich deine Nummer. Es ist ja jetzt sogar schon, also so Rufnummerunterdrückung ist ja so bei Werbeanrufen schon, da kannst du sofort abmahnen, wenn das passiert. Also kannst du sofort abnehmen und sagen, ich zeig sie an. Obwohl du gar nicht weißt, wen, aber...
Ach echt, ist das so?
Das ist neuerdings so, ja.
Ah, wusste ich noch gar nicht. Mich hat nämlich gestern Abend irgendwie Emdit angerufen und die hatten auch keine Nummer.
Ja, also Rufnummerunterdrückung ist nicht mehr zulässig bei sowas.
Schade, hätte ich ja gleich draufhauen können.
Und deswegen wird auch kommuniziert über diese Plattformen, über Messages und so, weil es eben diesen zweiseitigen Erlaubnis gibt und das eben ein bisschen reliable ist, dass es auch ankommt und dass es auch wirklich von dir ist und solche Sachen, was jetzt vielen Leuten bei E-Mail jetzt noch nicht so aufstößt. Aber was schon so unterschwellig da ist, diese Spam-Problematik weiß ja eigentlich jeder. Und kann auch sein, dass deswegen viele eben auf diese Social Networks gehen. Und natürlich ist es auch ein Generationenwechsel. Also die Erwachsenen benutzen halt E-Mail und die Jugend muss irgendwas machen, um nicht erwachsen auszusehen.
Ah, verstehe.
Und dadurch machen sie ihren eigenen Raum irgendwie auf einer Plattform oder dadurch leben natürlich auch die Telefonanbieter. SMS macht ja mehr Umsatz als andere wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eine Cash Cow, zumindest hier in Deutschland.
Und E-Mail benutzen die halt, um eine Entschuldigung an die Schule zu schreiben quasi. Oder sich für diese Konfirmationsgeschenke zu bedanken.
Mit den Alten zu reden. Ja, in dem Zusammenhang ist sicherlich auch Instant-Messaging zu nennen. Das lebt so ein bisschen zwischen den Welten. Das ist nicht wirklich so Web 2.0, obwohl es eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge damit zu tun hat. Jetzt müssen wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz oder endlich mal auch auf den Titel, den postulierten Titel dieser Sendung kommen. Conversational Design, alles andere als ein eingeführter Begriff. Ich habe ihn entnommen aus einem Posting, was du gemacht hast zu diesem Themenkomplex. Der ist auch nicht wirklich von dir, sondern wo kommt der her?
Pedro Custodio heißt der Kollege aus Portugal, der bei der Web 2 Expo letztes Jahr einen Vortrag gehalten hat, wo der Begriff eben auftauchte, auch schon in Patternform, also einfach um zu beschreiben, was es für Bausteine gibt, die im Design jetzt, also wirklich gestalterisch, aber auch konzeptionell eben, worauf dann Communities aufbauen und Dienste, die eben auf Konversationen basieren und auf Teilhabe. Also das geht dann von, naja, so ein Login ist auch schon so ein Baustein, also ich brauche ja einen Account und wie funktioniert das wirklich so, wirklich im Interaktionsablauf, Passwort vergessen, hier neue User und so.
Also wir reden jetzt von reinen Gebrauchsmustern, wie man Webseiten benutzt oder?
Wie man sie baut auch, und was für Features eine Plattform hat, um eben auch das Gespräch anzuregen und überhaupt zu ermöglichen. Also es gibt Kommentare, es gibt auch Gästebücher und so was, auf vielen. Und was ist so der Unterschied da? Oder es gibt Gruppen, Gruppen sind aber eigentlich nur Foren. Aber warum hat man nicht nur ein Forum, sondern muss Gruppen haben, die ein Thema haben? Also warum bezeichnen wir das als Gruppe? Und hat nicht nur offene Foren für Themen? Weil man sich eben identifiziert mit der Gruppe und sich da als Mitglied auch oft bewerben muss. Also bei Xing gibt es ja auch Gruppen zum Beispiel, da muss man sagen, warum man da Mitglied sein will und solche Sachen. Da gibt es eben so verschiedene Pattern. Das geht dann eben so in jeden Bereich, auch diese ganze Invite-Geschichte. Also wenn wirklich ein Dienst so jung ist, dass er noch Alpha ist, dann muss man ja oft eingeladen werden, um ihn überhaupt zu benutzen. Und wie funktioniert das? Also wie verschickt man die? Da gibt es auch, kann man so und so machen. Also entweder kenne ich deine E-Mail-Adresse und tate ich so ein, was irgendwie das Problem ist, dass ich deine E-Mail-Adresse weitergebe an den Dienst.
Ja, das ist populär derzeit.
Und man kann aber auch eine Invite-Code bekommen und den selbst verschicken, was da viel cleanere Weg wäre. So kann man sich die einzelnen Bausteine eben angucken und auch die Pattern erkennen, also die Muster erkennen. So im Webdesign gibt es eben schon so eine Musterbildung, Standardisierung von bestimmten Interaktionsmechanismen. Und gerade in diesem Bereich ging es eben sehr schnell, dass man sich so geeinigt hat, was funktioniert und gesehen hat und Sachen übernommen hat auch voneinander. Das geht halt bis zu Tagging und all diese Muster, die eben auch konzeptionell dahinter liegen.
Das zeugt schon von einer gewissen Reife des Mediums, würde ich sagen, dass man schon so weit gehen kann, sagen kann, okay, wir haben jetzt bestimmte Erfahrungen gesammelt, wir können jetzt hier ganz klare Muster erkennen, die man Baustein-mäßig auf neue Dienste werfen kann.
Naja, es hat schon auch gedauert, wenn man Interaktionsdesign an sich anguckt, so wie Navigationen funktionieren, also Menüs, wie auch immer, also Nutzer kennen diese Worte ja auch alle gar nicht, wie die funktionieren und dass die links sind und oben, also es gibt auch Seiten, wo die immer noch rechts sind, unten manchmal. Das ist ja immer noch im Fluss ein bisschen, aber es gibt ja schon Sachen, wo man sagt, die funktionieren. Oder wie ein Suchergebnis auszusehen hat.
Das ist aber jetzt eigentlich mehr so der Aspekt der Usability, oder?
Ja, aber das geht natürlich auch in diese Patterns mit ein. Also ein Kommentar als Kommentar erkennen können, als Kommentarfeld. Und am besten noch das eigene kleine Bild davor setzen, dass man weiß, dass man jetzt selbst spricht in diesem Feld und etwas sagen wird an dieses Objekt.
Ja gut, aber Conversational Design, also wenn ich jetzt von diesem konkreten Begriff ausgehe, da steckt ja wirklich auch die Kommunikation untereinander drin. Jetzt würde ich sagen, naja, so ein Login-Screen.
Ja, das ist nur so der Ansatz als Pattern. Aber klar, so die Kommunikationsmittel, die sind schon interessant und auch mehrstufig. Also es geht ja von, wenn man Facebook nimmt, von POKE. Also so ein, man drückt nur auf den Knopf, Kruscheln heißt das in Deutsch. Nur dieses Anstupsen. Oder noch tiefer ist eigentlich der Besuch des Profils, wäre auch schon so ein implizites POKE quasi. Ja. Wenn es der Dienst hat als Liste quasi, wer war auf meinem Profil?
So wie Berg Shing.
Ja, Berg Shing ist es ja sogar schon so, dass man das Feature bezahlen muss, wenn man sehen will, wer es wirklich war und woher er kam. Also ist quasi dieses Besuchen schon so viel wert. Also ist für mich quasi auch so ein Hauptpunkt, warum man es bezahlen würde.
Ja, das ist so wie Kontakte sammeln auf einer Messe, sozusagen. Wer hat sich denn für mich interessiert?
Ja, noch interessanter Berg Shing eben auch, der Referrer wird eben mit angegeben. Also nach welchem Feld hat er gesucht? Also wenn da steht, gesucht nach Vornamen, Nachnamen, dann weiß ich, dass er wirklich mich gesucht hat. Und wenn er steht nur nach Branche und Stadt, dann weiß ich, dass er irgendwie, er hat jetzt einen Grafiker in Berlin gesucht. Und so kann ich schon noch ein bisschen mehr wissen. Oder hat in den Kontakten von dem und dem geklickt. Also das ist schon Geld wert quasi als Interaktionsform.
Können wir denn mal so eine kleine Hall of Fame erstellen, welche von diesen Gebrauchsmustern, insbesondere den kommunikationsrelevanten Mustern, denn jetzt wirklich erfolgreich waren? Wir blicken jetzt auf, ja, was weiß ich, wann kam das mit dem Web 2.0 auf? Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr. Das sind noch mehr als drei Jahre, oder?
2004.
Also vier Jahre, irgendwie sowas.
Vielleicht ein bisschen länger.
Vielleicht sind es schon fünf, je nachdem, wie man dann drauf schaut. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt sehr viele Seiten, haben bekommen und gehen sehen. Einige haben es geschafft, sich über die ganze Zeit halbwegs populär zu halten. Bei manchen mag es irgendwie schwanken. Ich glaube, insgesamt dürfte die Zahl der Leute, die alles benutzt, enorm angewachsen sein, weil wir es einfach nach wie vor mit einem Sogeffekt zu tun haben. Die Leute stürzen ins Internet, die entdecken überhaupt diese ganzen Funktionalitäten und entdecken vielleicht überhaupt erst mal, was sie selbst davon haben könnten. Jenseits dieses Hypes von, mach ich schon einmal an die 90er-Jahre denken, mit irgendwie surfen und in die Cyber-Welten eintauchen und online sein und so. Das sind ja alles so Begriffe, die langsam aussterben und jetzt wird das Ganze so ein bisschen mehr wie so eine Schreibmaschine und die Leute fangen wirklich an, das auch wirklich zu benutzen. Ich würde mal sagen, auch diese Patterns als solche zu erkennen oder auch schon als gegeben vorauszusetzen.
Ja und auch dann entsprechend einzusetzen. Also für das eine benutze ich dies und fürs andere das.
Was sind denn dann so die populären Dinge? Also was braucht man?
Als Plattform.
Was braucht man als Plattform, was braucht man aber auch als oder was ist für Nutzer wirklich interessante Sachen? Letztlich kommt es natürlich auch auf die Verquickung und Kombination von all dem an. Es gibt ja auch viele, die stecken dann alles Mögliche rein, so das war da und da erfolgreich, das ballere ich auch noch mit rein. Aber versagen dann sozusagen an der Stelle, dem Benutzer klar zu machen, wofür diese Plattform jetzt eigentlich im Wesentlichen ist, weil man irgendwie alles haben kann und dann kriegt man dann so viel von allem, dass man gar nicht mehr durchblickt.
Also wichtig ist natürlich, dass es irgendwie ein Social Object gibt pro Plattform, dass es irgendwie ein Objekt gibt, um das es geht. Und wenn, entweder ist es ein Video, Fotos, Musik oder Status- Nachrichten, Twitter, so. Oder es ist irgendwas anderes, es ist bei Dick irgendwie ein Link. Also dass es immer irgendeinen Kristallisationspunkt gibt, wo ich sagen, wo ich mich identifizieren kann und wo ich drüber reden kann, es gibt natürlich auch die, also ne, Xing ist es dann irgendwie mein Beruf im Prinzip. Und Studio VZ ist es schon eher ich als mein ich, als mein digitales, als sich entwickelnder junger Mensch. Also es geht ja mehr darum. Aber es muss immer so ein Object geben, das ich dann auf Karten setzen kann und wo ich annotieren kann und kommentieren kann und so weiter. Und die zweite Ebene ist dann das Kommunizieren der Menschen untereinander über Nachrichten oder in Gruppen als Formen offengelegt oder eben private Nachrichten und Gästebücher. Also diese wirklich zwischen den Personen und vom Objekt dann wieder abgekoppelte Ebene.
Gästebücher eigentlich ein erfolgreiches Muster?
Naja, jetzt nicht so im Sinne von auf einer Website habe ich noch ein Gästebuch. Früher gab es das ganz viel, ich hab das nie benutzt. MySpace ist natürlich schon ein komplettes Gästebuch. Das besteht nur daraus letztlich. Und Facebook ist auch zum Großteil ein Wall. Ist ja ein Gästebook.
Die Wall, wo man so draufschreiben kann.
Genau, meine Wand.
Ich lasse die Features auch mal gerne erklären, das eine oder andere kenne ich, aber auch ich.
Das ist schon relativ populär. Ist schon ein populärer Pattern im Prinzip. Also etwas schreiben können, ohne dass man eine Antwort unbedingt erwartet. Das ist das eine. Öffentliches, antwortloses Draufschreiben. Und das andere ist eben das private Nachrichtsschreiben. Und ein Forum ist wiederum Antwort erwarten, aber trotzdem öffentlich und nicht an der Person gebunden. Na ja, das ist schon erstaunlich, wie ausdifferenziert das eben ist. So auch im Anspruch, was will welches, welcher Baustein so dann auslösen.
Ja, und das ist auch erstaunlich, dass die Leute das auch so unterscheiden können.
Und auch kapieren, ja, und auch die können das natürlich nicht formulieren so, wahrscheinlich. Aber sie wissen, welches man anwendet, in welchem Fall. Und man sieht, es fällt auch auf, wenn es missbraucht wird sozusagen. Da fällt es am meisten auf. Also bei Xing zum Beispiel, wenn jemand verbietet, dass man ihm private Nachrichten schicken kann, dann kann man ihm immer noch ins Gästebuch schreiben.
Was sei denn, er verbietet das auch?
Ja, aber das siehst du häufig bei Leuten, die wirklich entweder sehr bekannt sind oder so oder eben viele Leute kennen oder irgendetwas, für die das einfach zu viel Lärm wäre jetzt da, es auch noch zu erlauben. Da siehst du das häufig, dass Leute dann in Gästebücher schreiben, was eigentlich privat gedacht ist. Man merkt das schnell, wenn was auch nicht richtig benutzt wird. Das merken eigentlich alle. Das sind schon so die Bausteine, mit denen Kommunikation stattfindet. Wenn man noch tiefer geht, dann auch taggen und annotieren an Objekte. Dann sich Sachen empfehlen, noch explizit.
Taggen und annotieren an Objekte, da fällt mir ein, dass Facebook unter anderem die Möglichkeit bietet, Leute in Fotos zu identifizieren.
Studie verzeiht auch, glaube ich, und Flickr natürlich erst recht. Also Facebook ist nicht erfunden.
Ach, auf Flickr geht das auch? Direkt auf User-Accounts?
Gute Frage, bei Appernity geht das auf jeden Fall.
Du bist ja jetzt kein Flickr-User mehr. Appernity, ist das zu empfehlen?
Na ja, das ist im Prinzip ein Nachbau mit ein paar mehr Features. Man kann auch da gut Videos und Audio drin verwalten. Ja, klar, aber bei Facebook zum Beispiel kriegst du das natürlich auch mitgeteilt. Und kannst, glaube ich, sogar das entfernen selbst. Also Facebook hat schon ganz gute Privacy-Funktionen. Also auch das Einstellen, wer was sehen darf und wer was in gefeedet bekommt. Und ich will die Sachen nicht sehen und die will ich auch nicht schicken. Es sind schon ganz gut. Also die nehmen natürlich...
Wenn man das versteht.
Wenn man versteht, was da gemeint ist damit. Ja klar.
Das ist glaube ich gar nicht so einfach, einzuschätzen, wie man eigentlich dann in der Summe nach außen hin wirklich noch abstrahlt.
Einzuschätzen auch natürlich nicht nur...
Technisch was passiert, sondern vor allem auch, welche Auswirkungen das hat.
Dass das dann letztlich irgendwie im großen Google landet auch. Diese Einschätzung fehlt natürlich vielen Leuten. Oder Abschätzung sagen wir mal so.
Wird das noch kommen? Ist den Leuten das egal?
Man kann schon so darauf warten, dass es irgendwann mal ein Problemfall gibt, der auch so viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt, dass die Leute mehr drüber nachdenken. Also ich warte eigentlich längst darauf, dass es diesen Identitätsdiebstahl mal wirklich so gibt, dass er schlimm war. Also man weiß natürlich, dass... Schlimmer als jetzt Kreditkarten klauen. Das weiß man auch und das wird aber auch nicht wirklich bekannt, wenn es mal passiert. Aber dieses, ich habe mich als du ausgegeben und auf einer Plattform deine Freunde befreundet und deswegen irgendwie ich selbst Probleme bekomme. Also weil es ist ja nicht so schwer, irgendwo schneller zu sein als jemand anders und so weiter. Und man macht sich da schon ein bisschen eingreifbar, wenn man nicht authentisch woanders kommuniziert, dass man auch auf einer dritten Plattform dann erkennen würde, dass es nicht wirklich ich bin. Also es wäre ganz schwierig, glaube ich, für dich zu unterscheiden, ob ich das wirklich bin oder nicht auf irgendwas Neuem. Weil da habe ich, wie ist das connected? Das ist mein User-Name.
Du musst gucken, ob du auf den anderen Plattformen genauso langweilig bist, wie auf dem, den du schon kennst.
Genau, daran könnte man es machen. Aber ich selbst würde es vielleicht gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ja klar, ist schwierig. Man macht ja gleich mal wieder zehn neue Dienste auf, aber wenn man dann irgendwann mal so ein bisschen die Kraft verloren hat, jedem dann auch sofort, wenn das Kosmar-Syndrom sozusagen nachlässt, so kann es ja sein, dass irgendjemand anders das Leben weiterführt. Da gibt es ja auch jetzt interessante technische Entwicklungen. OpenID muss man da auf jeden Fall nennen, so als technischen Unterbau. Da wollte ich eigentlich auch ganz gerne schon immer mal was bringen. Hab bloß noch keinen passenden Experten gefunden, aber ich habe auch so den Eindruck, das benutzen noch nicht so richtig viele. Also OpenID, die Grundidee vielleicht nochmal schildern.
Naja, es funktioniert so, dass du bei einem OpenID-Provider deiner Wahl, das kannst du im Zweifel sogar selbst sein, wenn du technisch das kannst, deine Daten hinterlegst. Also so viele du willst und auch so viele unterschiedliche Personen, wie du willst. Also du kannst Personas auch machen.
Identitäten sozusagen.
Also mehrere Namen haben und Datensätze. Und wenn eine Plattform dann OpenID unterstützt, dann logge ich mich da nur mit einer URL ein, die auf mein OpenID-Profil weist. Und werde dann eben weitergeleitet zu dem Provider, der URL dann zu finden ist. Und dort erlaube ich dann dieser Plattform, die das anfragt, welchen Persona und welche Daten von diesem Datensatz eben notwendig sind oder welche ich da abgeben will. Und das ist für den Nutzer insofern natürlich ein großer Vorteil, weil er einerseits die Daten nicht überall eingeben muss. Sie auch nicht nur zentral ändern muss. Kein Passwort sich da ausdenken muss. Also du hast dann eben nur dieses eine Passwort. Die Identifizierung funktioniert eben über OpenID-Server und nicht mehr der Plattform selbst.
Beziehungsweise man kann es glaube ich auch so machen, dass man sich nicht mal über ein Passwort, sondern unter Umständen einen etwas sichereren Mechanismus, sehr viel mehr Verschlüsselungen und so weiter, von diesen Mechanismen sozusagen einloggt.
Und so hast du eben eine zentrale Verwaltung von deinen Daten plus diese verstreuten Passwörter nicht mehr. Und natürlich für die Dienste im Prinzip auch nicht schlecht, weil sie dann diese ganze Verwaltung davon eigentlich nicht machen müssen. Das ist natürlich noch nicht so beliebt, dass Dienste auf ihre eigene Nutzerverwaltung deswegen verzichten würden. Das wird immer parallel eigentlich angeboten. Aber es gibt schon Firmen, große Firmen, die das auch unterstützen und anbieten. AOL, Yahoo, Blogger, Google.
Aber müssten nicht diese Social Networks selbst eigentlich auch noch diesen Dienst anbieten? Hätten sie nicht daran eigentlich ein großes Interesse, dass man sozusagen sein Profil bei Xing quasi als das Primärprofil nimmt und sich dann damit bei anderen...
Das wäre für einen Nutzer sicher toll. Aber Social Networks, die als als Kern Social Object nur das Profil haben, also die Person selbst, für die ist diese Daten natürlich ihr Hauptwert.
Na gut, aber genau, dann würden sie sicher sozusagen, dann wäre es ja der beste Grund dann bei diesem System auch immer zu bleiben und da immer auch das aktuell zu halten, wenn man das quasi als Hauptquelle nimmt.
Stimmt schon, wäre schon interessant. Also Xing ersetzt ja für viele auch schon das Adressbuch so mit. Und wenn es auch noch das Login quasi ersetzen würde woanders, wüsste Xing natürlich auch, wo ich irgendwo angemeldet bin. Hätte vielleicht auch so ein Anreiz, natürlich für eine Firma das mitzumachen.
Wie ist denn das mit dieser ganzen... Ich meine, viele Leute, die jetzt zuhören, warten jetzt sozusagen darauf, dass ich die große Keule auspacke und sozusagen jetzt hier diese mangelnde Privatsphäre im Internet bemängle. Gut, klar, das ist natürlich so eine Sache. Man muss immer wissen, was man von sich selber veröffentlicht. Allerdings, denke ich, muss man auch zur Kenntnis nehmen, ein so erschlagen großer Teil der Leute, für die ist das offensichtlich nicht das Wichtigste. Da schlummern alle möglichen Gefahren, wie du schon gesagt hast. Wir warten jetzt eigentlich sozusagen nur auf den ersten Super-GAU. Aber es ist ja ganz offensichtlich so, dass es für die Leute so eine Erleichterung zu sein scheint, dass sie sich darüber keine Gedanken machen. Wie hältst du das selber? Wie ertrickst du denn diese Web-Öffentlichkeit?
Na ja, erstens bist du natürlich selbst schon zu einem großen Teil verantwortlich. Also du entscheidest natürlich, was du da machst und wie viel es ist und mit wem das ist letztlich. Und natürlich gehört dazu ein gewisses Verständnis, wie das Ganze irgendwie nachher funktioniert. Aber ich glaube, das haben die Leute schon auch zum gewissen Teil. Also dieses, ich trag da nicht alle Daten ein. Was wollen die von mir? Das haben eigentlich die ganz normalen Menschen ja schon auch. Und da muss der Vorteil, den ich da sehe, schon groß sein, dass ich viel Preis gebe. Das ist vielleicht auch eine Generationsfrage. Also jemand Jüngeres macht das vielleicht eher.
Gibt es dir überhaupt viel Preis oder ist das alles gelogen, was du über dich im Internet hast?
Im Prinzip ist es alles gelogen. Es ist immer natürlich nicht so privat. Man muss sich immer überlegen, wenn ich da was ins Internet reinschreibe, dann müsste ich eigentlich auch in der Lage sein, das auf der Straße irgendwie laut zu brüllen. Und das nicht nur laut zu brüllen, sondern im Prinzip auch auf die Straße hinzuschreiben, riesengroß. Und das muss man schon wissen. Und ich habe schon auch Bereiche, die ich nicht veröffentliche. Also ich schreibe durchaus in Twitter viel rein und ich mache auch Fotos. Aber es gibt Sachen, die ich nicht fotografiere und Sachen, die ich nicht ins Internet stelle. Und es gibt auch sogar Dinge, über die ich...
Zum Beispiel Familie.
Ja, sicher. Und auch wenn ich meinen Ort preisgebe, dann ist es schon eine Abwägungssache. Es muss einen Vorteil haben, dass ich den Ort preisgebe. Also es muss für mich toll aussehen. Toll, da war der. Das muss schon rausspringen, sonst ist es schwierig. Solche Dinge. Und es gibt auch Sachen, über die ich gar nicht schreibe. Weil, keine Ahnung, da begrenzt man sich natürlich auch selbst so, wie man das im Kopf hat. Also schreibt mal was über jemanden, von dem man schon gearbeitet hat, zum Beispiel. Und auch wenn das schon lange her ist, macht man das. Oder für den man vielleicht arbeiten will noch, schreibt man da drüber. Schon interessant, wie man sich da selbst begrenzt auch manchmal, wo es auch nicht nötig wäre. Aber man sollte bei jedem Dingen überlegen, was man tut. Und da eben auch nicht weniger als sonst.
Denkst du, die Anbieter der Dienste sollten den Leuten dabei auch helfen, diese Auswahl zu treffen? Gibt es da vielleicht ein schönes Pattern, was man da empfehlen kann?
Was wirklich wichtig ist, ist tatsächlich so diese Eingrenzung der Privatsphäre. Also, dass der Dienstnummer alles von mir weiß, was ich da einstelle. Es ist irgendwie eminent im System. Also kaum Dienst irgendwie legt die Daten irgendwo anders ab, wo sie dann selbst nicht ran können. Das wäre den Diensten etwas zu viel des Guten. Aber zum Beispiel OpenID ist auch schon so ein Weg, zu sagen, gut, wir wollen eure Daten nicht wirklich, aber ihr dürft euch hier einloggen. Oder OAuth irgendwie, wo man einen Dienst auch definitiv identifiziert, auf die Daten von einem anderen Dienst zuzugreifen, ohne dass man jetzt Passwort ab Preis gibt.
O-A-U-T-H. Das ist im Prinzip so eine Nachbildung, ist das ein Open Source Projekt? Das ist so eine Nachbildung, dieser Zugangskontrolle, wie man sie von Flickr kennt.
Ja, wo Drittanbieter durch die offene API-Struktur, gibt es eben viele Dritte, die auch auf mehr Daten zugreifen wollen oder sollten, als man irgendwie öffentlich kann, also die wirklich in den Dienst eingreifen müssen, um ihren Dienst wiederum darauf aufzubauen.
Wir räumen das vielleicht noch mal kurz aus. Also API, das ist ja auch so ein Wesensmerkmal, das haben wir so noch gar nicht erwähnt, der Web 2.0-Anwendung. Man ist in zunehmendem Maße dahingegangen, nicht eben nur so ein Menscheninterface übers Web zu machen, sondern es gibt auch maschinenlesbare Interfaces, um eben Hilfsprogramme zu machen. Das haben auch schon frühe Dienste. Amazon war, glaube ich, mit den ersten, die überhaupt so was angeboten haben. Da könnte man dann seinen eigenen Job machen. Man nutzt sozusagen die Mechanismen von Amazon. Bei Ebay ist es ähnlich für diese ganzen Auktionsprogramme und auch die ganzen anderen Webdienste, Facebook und so haben alle ihre eigene API.
Ja, Facebook nicht so richtig. Nach außen sind die nicht so offen wie zu sich rein. Die holen viel auf die Plattform drauf, aber rauskriegst aus Facebook nicht viel.
Okay, aber sie haben einen API. Das ist ja das, was ich eigentlich meine. Bei Flickr war es so, dass wenn ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, ich benutze jetzt hier so, habe jetzt mein lokales Fotoverwaltungsprogramm und du schmeißt da so ein Plugin rein, mit dem es eben leicht ist, das hochzuladen, dann muss sich dieses Tool erstmal autorisieren. Das ist dieser Mechanismus, dass man sozusagen diesem Programm in dem Moment dann auch gestartet, da eine Verbindung zu diesem Dienst aufzunehmen, dass da nicht jeder einfach reinrauschen kann.
Genau, also da kommt der Dienst, der aufbaut oder der auch vielleicht ein Mesh-up machen will aus mehreren Sachen. Oder wenn das ein Livestream-Tool ist, wo ich mehrere Sachen zusammenfassen will, wo ich Twitterflicker und meine YouTube-Favoriten gleichzeitig veröffentlichen will auf meinem Blog, dann muss der Blog oder der dritte Dienst auf die Daten zugreifen, vielleicht auf einer tieferen Ebene als RSS das könnte. Und dafür gibt es eben diese Schnittstelle Oauth oder so ein Standard, wo eben die Plattform dann anfragt und du als authentifizierter Nutzer bei Flicker dann zum Beispiel, der sagt dann okay, dieser andere Dienst, der meine Karten mit meinen Bildern irgendwas anderes machen will, der darf das. Und so muss ich nicht dem Dienst mein Passwort geben, mit dem sie dann alles machen könnten, sondern ich kann auch noch regeln, wie viel darf das und was genau darf es. Das darf nur schicken oder nur lesen oder nur schreiben und solche Dinge. Und diese Einstellungen, die sollte es eben nicht nur für Applikationen geben, sondern eben auch für Nutzer, also für Menschen. Die Leute dürfen so und so viel sehen von meinem Profil und Google darf es gar nicht sehen. Diese Privacy-Einstellungen, was erlaub ich Programm, was erlaub ich anderen Mitgliedern, was erlaub ich meinen Freunden oder was Flickr zum Beispiel auch gemacht hat oder macht, ist ja, du kannst ein Bild, eine gewisse Privacy geben, dass es privat ist, dass es öffentlich ist oder dass es Freunde sehen können. Oder, dass es die Familie sehen kann. Also du kannst ja Kontakte einordnen in Familie oder Freunde oder Kontakte. Was schon interessant ist, weil du kannst da exklusive Freunde geben, aber die Familie darf es nicht sehen. Und die Familie darf Sachen sehen, die die Freunde nicht sehen.
Nebeneffekt ist, man erzählt natürlich den System dann auch ziemlich genau, wer wer ist, wer hier wirklich Freunde sind und wie man dazu steht. Und das ist natürlich dann nochmal besonders sensitiv. Also das ist schon alles ziemlich knifflig.
Genau, und wenn man jetzt noch so überlegt, dass es eher in die Richtung geht, auch diese ganzen semantischen Kontaktdaten quasi und auch deren Daten wiederum mitnehmen zu können. Also das ist so die nächste Stufe mit Open Social und Data Portability, dass du als Nutzer entscheiden kannst, ich nehme meinen ganzen Klumpen an Daten, nicht nur von mir selbst, sondern auch wen ich kenne und deren Daten zum Teil, die die dafür freigegeben haben, den kann ich nehmen und auf woanders hintragen und da reinschmeißen und so. Und das alles eins wird irgendwie am Ende. Alles wird eins, das wäre schon toll.
Außer der Null. Wo geht es denn jetzt hin? In letzter Zeit, neben den ganzen Foto- und textbasierten Diensten und den Social-Network-Portal hat natürlich auch der Videoteil noch mal extrem angezogen. Natürlich YouTube, auch da konnte man immer schon kommentieren und beantworten und abonnieren.
YouTube war erfolgreich, weil es MySpace gab und Leute eben Filme benutzt haben, um dort die Profile schicker zu machen. Die Erfolge hängen natürlich voneinander ab. Auf Webflickr war die API und was da drumrum gebaut wurde, bei Twitter auch im Übrigen. Also die ganzen Use-Cases und alles, was man machen kann mit Twitter. Da gibt es ja mehrere hundert irgendwie Trittplattformen, die mit den Daten dann was machen und auch schöne Sachen machen und auch wahrscheinlich nicht so viele.
Trittbrettfahrer.
Tritt mit D.
Und Video, klar, ist auch so was, was eben durch die Bandbreite auch bedingt ist natürlich jetzt und auch, dass es eben auch mobil irgendwie schon ein bisschen funktioniert, ein bisschen besser. Ist da schon interessant, dass mobil im Sinne von Handy, aber auch Laptop, ja, also dass diese Webcams eingebaut sind und dass Handys eben Kameras haben. Das ist was und die Bandbreite, die für Video irgendwie notwendig ist, die ist auch irgendwie da. Und dadurch passiert jetzt einiges so in dem Bereich von Live-Video. Also wirklich, wo man früher gesagt hat, irgendwie Flickr, Flickr, da wurde ja auch zum ersten Mal so richtig dieses mobile Posten. Also ein Foto vom Handy direkt auf Flickr schicken, krass. Das war irgendwie vor drei Jahren das Krasseste, was man konnte. Und heute kann ich halt Live-Video streamen auf Quick oder auf ein paar anderen Plattformen, Flickswaggen oder so. Und das ist jetzt so das Ende quasi der Fahnenstange, was im Moment geht. Und solche Sachen wie Mogulus ist also eine Plattform, wo ich mit der Webcam dann quasi schon Fernsehen nachahmen kann. Also da kann ich live reinsenden und kann hunderte Zuschauer haben und kann dann von YouTube-Videos da drüber abspielen und kann auch die Kamera dann abgeben an dich, wo du ganz in Japan sitzt. Und daneben ist ein Chat, wo dann Feedback kommt. Und kann ich schon eigentlich mehr als Fernsehen abbilden, mit dieser Feedback.
Man hat so sein eigenes Sendeschirm.
Und es ist relativ einfach auch zu machen. Da gibt es noch mehr.
Ja, da treuert man ja als Podcaster eigentlich auch davon. Für einen Podcaster gibt es allerdings noch keine Plattform, die irgendwie wirklich...
Audio, es gab mal Audio, was nicht so richtig funktioniert hat damals.
Ja, da hab ich zumindest nie so richtig verstanden, was die eigentlich von mir wollten. Also gut, da gab es so die Möglichkeit, Kommentare abzusetzen und so. Aber ich glaube, da ist dieser Live-Aspekt auch viel interessanter. Ich meine, wir senden jetzt hier auch live. Wir werden jetzt glaube ich keine Zeit haben, noch live Feedback mit reinzuholen. Aber natürlich gibt es viele Formate, wo das auch wunderbar funktionieren würde. So richtig ist Talk Radio zum Beispiel, wo man eben Leute befragt.
Aber das ist schon interessant, dass das Audio übersprungen wurde und jetzt gleich Video gemacht wird.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich so übersprungen wurde. Also ich meine, Audio-Streaming, das geht ja nun schon wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr lange. Wurde im Podcast-Bereich vielleicht noch nicht so viel verwendet, wie jetzt das mit dem Video losgeht. Video hat natürlich auch immer gleich diese Aufmerksamkeit. Man hat das ganz gut gemerkt, als es so diese Phase gab von Web 2.0-Diensten oder sagen wir mal diese Partizipation, dieses jeder kann mitmachen Ding. Das war sehr schön zu sehen, drei Jahre hintereinander. Erst kamen Blogs, die waren natürlich schon vorher da, aber als Blogs so richtig knallten, das war so 2004 ungefähr. Da war das auf einmal groß im Gespräch, die gab es natürlich schon ein paar Jahre, aber auf einmal war das so die Entdeckung. Oh Mann, Wahnsinn. Privatpersonen können Seiten im Internet schreiben, nicht, da kam dieser Mythos mit Internet-Tagebuch, den werden wir so schnell nicht loswerden, aber ist natürlich alles Quatsch. Leute haben gelernt, selber privat und auf eine sehr persönliche Art und Weise zu kommunizieren und bis heute wird es zwar missverstanden, aber ich denke, die Leute, die wirklich mehr Einblick haben, schnallen schon, dass Blogs natürlich so eine der Grundkommunikationsmittel der Zukunft ist, sehe ich zumindest so. Das ist einfach etwas, Bloggen muss man irgendwie lernen und können und dann kann man das auch für viele Sachen nutzen und diese ganzen Vergleiche mit Journalismus und Blogs, das ist irgendwie total armer. Da habe ich mal ein schönes Zitat gehört, gelesen, weiß gar nicht mehr, wo es herkommt, so auf die Frage, naja, wie ist denn das so? Sind denn Blogger die besseren Journalisten? So meinte er, da könnte man auch fragen, sind Fahrradfahrer irgendwie die besseren Autos? Sind Fahrräder die besseren Autos? Also wo schnell klargemacht wird, es handelt sich hier einfach, man ist zwar auch am kommunizieren, so wie man mit dem Fahrrad auch am Fahren ist, aber es ist einfach nicht vergleichbar. Dann kam der zweite Schritt, dann kamen die Podcasts, erst mal mit Audio 2005, und man sagt, oh Wahnsinn, so jetzt kann irgendwie jeder Radio machen, man kann das abonnieren, das ist toll, und Leute plappern da tatsächlich was rein. Alles immer auch gefolgt von so zwei, drei Jahren totaler Ernüchterung, so, und man gesagt hat, oh jetzt haben wir das so gefeiert, mir ist das doch nichts passiert, so, es ist immer noch alles langweilig, immer noch so dieselben Leute am Start, die das am Anfang gemacht haben, nicht begreifen, dass es halt einfach auch drei Jahre dauert, bis so was Feuer nimmt. Und dann 2006, YouTube, wie alle fragen sich, oh Gott, was will denn Google dann mit, warum kaufen die denn YouTube, was soll denn das mit diesem Video, das ist doch alles alberne, das sind doch alles alberne Clips. Und schön viele verpasste Chancen, worauf will ich hinaus, dadurch, dass ich das jetzt alles nochmal wiederhole, was ja jeder kennt, die klassischen Medien, die haben sich das alles mit so einer stoischen Ruhe angeschaut und dachten, das tangiert uns nicht. Wie siehst du denn das neue Netzgeflecht und so die klassischen Dienste?
Naja, also das wird, wie du sagst, natürlich auch nicht ersetzen und ist auch gar nicht als Konkurrenz irgendwie so geplant. Auch nicht von den Menschen, die das machen. Also wer will schon irgendwie die Zeitung ersetzen? Oder Telefon. Aber es gibt natürlich so eine zweite Ebene oder so eine innere Schicht dann wieder, wo man sagen kann, also es nimmt ja auch der Fernsehkonsum ab und der Internetkonsum nimmt irgendwie zu. Und die Leute gucken jetzt nicht unbedingt wieder Fernsehen nur da drüber. Also es gibt so diese Begriffe von lean back und lean forward Medien, wo du dich beim Fernsehen einfach zurücklehnst und wo du dich aber bei YouTube dann schon wieder nach vorne lehnst und dann schon noch Kommentare reinschreibst. Und dann gibt es noch Jump in, wo du wirklich in den Bildschirm springst und dann die Kamera auf dich selbst hältst und das selbst machst. Das ist auch nicht neu, Begriffe gibt es auch schon.
Ich habe es erstmal gehört, lean forward und jump in.
Und wenn du dann so Mogulus siehst, dann bist du schon echt reingesprungen. Klar, also das eine ist ja das Produzieren und es werden immer nur einer von mehr als 100 produzieren und der Rest wird es konsumieren. Aber was konsumieren die Mainstream-Medien oder zum Teil auch Medien, denen sie vertrauen, nämlich Sachen aus ihrem Umfeld oder der soziale Umfeld, was es jetzt auch immer sei, ob das jetzt die echten Freunde sind oder die online 48-Pixel-Freunde. Trotzdem haben die da einen anderen Bezug zu und wissen das anders einzuschätzen als die Tagesschau. Und das ergänzt sich dann irgendwie. Also Social Media ist schon so ein Begriff für das Ganze. Und das deckt dann schon ab einmal diese Konsumwelt, die Empfehlungswelt, Musikprodukte, Bücher, Reisen, was auch immer. Also wo kann ich hingehen? Was macht man jetzt so in meinem Umfeld? Plus dieses Umfeld, das liefert natürlich auch Auszüge aus dem großen Weltgeschehen und empfiehlt mir. Oder worüber diskutiert man denn jetzt? Also wenn in Burma irgendwas passiert, wie das letztes Jahr war, dann geht das durch die Blogs durch. Und hat dann so eine andere Qualität, als wenn man das nur konsumiert, als Fernsehzeitung, Radio. Und involviert einen dann auch anders. Oder wie geht man mit China um und so. Da ist man anders gefordert auch als Konsument. Das Medium.
Das kann auch schon anstrengend werden.
Das kann es ja.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass dazu alle so bereit sind.
Ja, immer eine Meinung zu haben, ist auch schwierig.
Ist klar.
Ist schon richtig. Aber die Meinung zu übernehmen von jemandem, dem man näheres Gefühl für hat als Fernsehsender, das ist dann schon wieder eine andere Qualität. Also wenn jemand in meinem Umfeld sagt, hier, die machen da Quatsch, in, weiß nicht, irgendwo in der Welt, dann übernehme ich das eher oder anders und das gibt einen anderen Aspekt für Meinungsbildung.
Web 2.0 hat sozusagen mehr Meinungsquellen.
Ja, und du kannst sie anders qualifizieren. Also das ist halt nicht die Bild-Zeitung und das ist halt nicht der Spiegel und so. Das heißt, das ist Chaosradio Express. Genau und das hat natürlich bezieht es seine Informationen auch nur aus der Welt, die alle anderen auch kennen, aber es hat einen eigenen Kopf und den mische ich mit rein in meine Meinungsbildung und irgendwann sage ich selbst was dazu. Und so diese Konversation dann wieder.
Man lernt sozusagen auch das Meinungsbilden.
Genau, also natürlich gibt es, sprechen Leute ja auch miteinander so, ohne Elektrik dazwischen und da passiert ja das Gleiche. Man unterhält sich über Themen und bildet sich gegenseitig die Meinung ab und bildet sie dadurch.
Wenn ich so Diskussionen über Podcasts habe, übrigens dann Leute sozusagen, versuche klar zu machen, was Podcasts ausmachen oder was das Interesse der Leute daran ist, dann ist das auch einer der Punkte, die ich immer nenne, dass ich einfach den Eindruck habe, dass Leute Podcasts, also vor allem das Interesse am gesprochenen Wort haben, aber vor allem auch ein Interesse an Meinungen haben, dass Formate insbesondere dann interessant sind, wenn sie eine eigene Meinung auch formulieren oder zumindest soweit die Dinge reflektieren, dass man daraus eine Meinung oder eine Grundtendenz ablesen kann, dass das es auch wert ist, die Zeit zu investieren. Und sicherlich ist es bei Blogs ähnlich. In der Videowelt bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher. Die kann eigentlich nicht groß anders sein. Trotzdem ist Video unglaublich zeitaufwendig, um das zu wahrzunehmen, weil man auch so zugedonnert wird mit Inhalten.
Na ja, auch mit drei Szenen muss man da aufpassen und so.
Drei?
Na ja, wenn du den Feedback-Kanal noch...
Achso, das ist auch ein Sinn, das tippen?
Ja, also wenn du dieses Lean Forward hast, dann ist ja zu, du musst gucken, hören und dann auch so antworten, reagieren, quasi mit chatten. Das ist ja dann, dann ist dein Gehirn ganz drauf.
Ist das auch sozusagen das Schreiben, eine Wahrnehmung?
Na ja, das drüber nachdenken, ja.
Na ja, okay, stimmt, man muss sozusagen, achso, die nächste Stufe meinst du, also dass man das auch verarbeitet. Interessanter Punkt.
Also das bindet dich natürlich, wenn du kannst Audio natürlich schon viel besser genug konsumieren und dann auch noch was anderes angucken dabei und immer noch dran denken. Ja klar. Das gilt natürlich für die großen Sachen quasi, also wenn man sich über ein Thema informiert oder mitbekommt, wie auch über die kleinen Dinge, also wie Twitter eben auch funktioniert. Es ist irgendwie schon, du weißt, dass jeder morgens Kaffee trinkt, aber wenn du es von irgendwie 100 Leuten gesagt bekommst morgens, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen anders.
Das nervt mich aber eher.
Natürlich nervt es auch.
Guten Morgen, Twitter. Das würde ich gerne rausfiltern.
Aber das gibt natürlich so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl, klar. Die anderen sind auch nicht anders als ich. Und bei Twitter ist es auch schön, du kannst natürlich jemanden folgen, zu dem du eigentlich hinaufblickst. Es sind ja auch Leute drin, die da, also irgendwie Kevin Rose von Dick, der ist glaube ich der, der am meisten Follower hat im Moment. Echt?
Follow ich aber nicht.
Sie kommunizieren natürlich auch super selten, aber was sie dann schreiben, hat natürlich für viele Leute ein großes Vorbildfunktion.
55.972 Follower. Der hat sogar mehr als Leola Portz. Das ist ja unglaublich. Das ist absurd, oder?
Das ist natürlich absurd.
Das ist echt absurd.
Aber du hast da die Möglichkeit, wirklich sehr nah an der Person zu sein. Also anders als ein Blog ist ja auch schon sehr persönlich und nah. Aber hier hast du es noch so in Echtzeit. Und die Vorstellung, Henry Rollins schreibt was in Twitter und ich krieg's als SMS. Der schreibt jetzt schon lange nichts mehr. Aber das ist schon eine andere Qualität von Fan sein dann letztlich.
Ja, es ist eine interessante Feedback. Ich merke das jetzt hier auch, seitdem ich Twitter auch ein bisschen bewusster als Begleitprogramm zum Podcasting einsetze. Ich bekomme halt immer mal wieder so kurze Hinweise, Tipps, jetzt natürlich auch während der Sendung, aber auch so allgemeineres Feedback. Und habe auch so den Eindruck von Leuten, die jetzt so vielleicht noch nicht mal vorher eine Mail geschrieben hätten. Also die Einstiegsschwelle ist einfach mal noch niedriger. Trotzdem ist es nicht so verspammt. Fast ein Wunder. Und ja, auf Twitter muss man eigentlich, kann man eigentlich häufig genug, ich bin total begeistert von Twitter aus. Ich bin auch immer, auch in zunehmendem Maße, skeptisch, was Dienste betrifft. Plus Twitter hat interessantes Problem gelöst. Insbesondere, also ich finde das conversational Design hier sozusagen an der Stelle am interessantesten, weil es eigentlich funktioniert wie so ein Chat, aber diesen Nervfaktor eines Chats nicht hat.
Ja, du kannst halt entscheiden, wem du zuhörst.
Genau.
Und du kannst einfach schreiben. Und du hast viele Wege es zu tun, auch zu lesen und zu schreiben. Du kannst dir den Weg eigentlich quasi wirklich selbst aussuchen, weil es so offen ist.
Auch das Werkzeug, weil es ja viele Kleins dafür gibt.
Und es hat natürlich eine Sache, die neu an Twitter ist, wirklich dieses Follow-Prinzip. Also es ist ein autentifiziertes Folgen. Also ich möchte dich empfangen, aber du musst mich nicht gleichzeitig empfangen.
Und vor allem ist es nicht diese komische Friend-Abstraktion, die mich schon immer so ein bisschen gestört hat bei vielen Diensten.
Das ist etwas, was da neu dran war damals. Also das ist diese Begrifflichkeit an sich. Und auch ein bisschen, wie es funktioniert.
Was ziehst du selbst heraus dann aus Twitter? Ich meine, dir folgen ja nun auch schon so einige Leute. 1627 ist der Aktuelle Score.
Na ja, wie gesagt, es geht natürlich darum, wie vielen du folgst. Weil ich lese ja jetzt nicht die 1600, sondern nur 900.
Du folgst 920 Leuten? Alter Falter, das rauscht doch nur noch grau durch.
Na ja, also das ist natürlich auch...
Oder folgst du nur den Leuten, die nichts sagen?
Eben, das sagen ja dann auch nach einer Weile manche nichts mehr. Deswegen ist die Zahl... also ich weiß nicht, das sind vielleicht 300, 400 aktive vielleicht.
Aber welches Prinzip hast du? Folgst du nur den Leuten, die du auch kennst?
Ne, die kenne ich natürlich nicht alle. Aber die interessant sind. Also das kann durchaus auch der Ort sein. Also sind die hier, ist schon ein Kriterium. Und dann so eine Empfehlungsebene. Wen kennen die oder wer kennt die? Das guckt man dann schon auch mal nach. Oder haben die einen Blog und kann ich den angucken und interessiert mich der? Und dann hat das vielleicht... Oder man guckt sich einfach an, was auf der Seite gerade aktuell steht und wenn es irgendwie okay ist und mich interessieren würde.
Ja, so ähnlich gehe ich auch vor.
Und klar.
Wobei ich Plappertaschen dann in der Regel schnell wieder aussortiere.
Das ist natürlich schon zu viel und ich kann nicht mehr alles lesen.
Ich kann doch nicht immer über das Frühstück informiert werden.
Klar. Und das Schöne ist eben, dass man das auch selbst einstellt. Man stellt natürlich ein, was will man sehen und was nicht. Also personenweise. Und kann man so machen. Und klar, das ist einerseits natürlich ein Publizieren, aber auch viel eher noch ein Mitnehmen und Lesen. Und Twitter ist ja jetzt schon so weit, dass da eben wirklich Informationen auch passieren.
Ist der Chat nicht eigentlich die stärkste Kommunikationsform? Ist das nicht das, was man bei Twitter irgendwie rausliest?
Ja. Zumindest die, weil du weißt, wer es liest, sozusagen. Und du weißt, und es ist in Echtzeit, kommt es an. Also das ist dann wirklich die Person und die Zeit. Wenn es jetzt noch zusätzlichen Ortaspekt hätte, dann wäre alles da. Also wenn ich jetzt auch noch gleichzeitig das so filtern kann, dass nur in der Umgebung ich das lese, dann wäre es ja schon fast wie echt, wenn du wirklich da wärst. Weil dann bist du in meiner Nähe und jetzt bist du in meiner Nähe.
Für Orte gibt es ja auch so einige Dienste. Benutzt du da irgendwas mit ortsbezogenen Sachen?
Ich bewege mich halt selten weit weg. Aber es gibt natürlich irgendwie Qwibes für Empfehlungen und es gibt Places, um sich zu organisieren und zu kommunizieren über anhand von Orten sozusagen. Oder Doppler, um Reisen zu publizieren und Gemeinsamkeiten festzustellen. Das sind schon, man sieht auch, das sind dann so Schichten auch. Doppler ist eigentlich weit entfernt von mir, wenn ich dahin gehe oder wenn jemand in meine Stadt kommt, von woanders, dafür ist es da. Das andere ist mehr so in meinem Umfeld. Wir organisieren uns und gehen dahin. Quaib ist mehr so eine abstrakte Ebene von ich suche etwas in einer Stadt. Es gibt auch so verschiedene Arten, um auf Orte zu gucken. Da wird natürlich dieses Mobiltelefon auch extrem interessant, weil das ja mit dir da ist, wo du bist. Und auch für dich sprechen kann. Also sobald das mal GPS eingebaut wird, wird was da passiert. Vielleicht könnte es sogar eine Vorschrift werden, dass das drin sein muss. In Amerika reden die glaube ich darüber, damit man dir helfen kann, falls du in Not kommst. Sobald das irgendwie drin ist, dann wird es auch möglicherweise ein Aspekt, der einfach normaler wird, zu sagen, wo ich bin. Ob du es jetzt wirklich publizieren musst. Du kannst ja da auch wieder die Privacy einregeln. Da würde man sicher auch einen Dienst nehmen, der das erlaubt und macht. Aber dass die Geräte in Zukunft immer mehr sprechen für dich. Wo du bist und was da gerade ist, weiß ja auch jemand anderes noch. Eventkalender weiß ja, wenn du zu der Zeit dort bist, dann bist du bei diesem Event. Und die Sachen zu verknüpfen wird sicher interessant. Oder natürlich auch für, wenn du einkaufen bist. Oder dein Gerät weiß ja auch, was für ein Zustand, welches Profil du eingestellt hast. Also bist du in einer Konferenz oder nicht. Und das zu übertragen auf das Adressbuch. Und ich kann dann gucken, wenn ich dich jetzt in meinem Adressbuch suche, bist du gerade überhaupt ansprechbar oder hast du eine Statusnachricht hinterlassen. Und so wird sich viel eben auf dieses mobile Web übertragen werden. Und das passiert ja heute schon. Also publizieren natürlich über die Kamera und den Ton. Und auch reintippen, aber auch das soziale Netz verfolgen darüber. Und plus die Geräte sprechen für dich. Das wird in Zukunft immer mehr passieren.
Ja, das Web 2.0 ist noch lange nicht am Ende. Aber wir sind jetzt am Ende. Die Sendung wird jetzt ein Ende finden, denn wir haben hier nur zwei Stunden. Wir sind live auf Funkwelle FM noch ein weiteres Mal. Nächsten Sonntag gibt es noch eine Sendung. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, habe ich noch kein Thema. Das heißt, ich habe so verschiedene Themen in Planung, aber das Thema steht noch nicht ganz fest. Das könnt ihr dann alles nachlesen auf chaosradio.ccc.de, wo man auch schön einen Kalender abonnieren kann, um so den Blick nach vorne zu haben für weitere Live-Sendungen. Da gibt es ja dann auch das Chaosradio, was einmal im Monat bei Fritz sendet. Und natürlich kann man die Sendung abonnieren als Podcast. Und das sollte man auch tun, wenn man Interesse hat an Chaosradio Express und den interessanten Gästen. Heute war es Kosmar. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Kann man sicherlich irgendwann auch nochmal einen Realitätsabgleich machen. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall spannend und ich wollte auch mal bewusst hier so einen nicht ganz so paranoia-schwangeren Blick auf die Dienstewelt machen. Natürlich, es hat alles irgendwie seine Risiken und Nebenwirkungen. Daran muss man sich bewusst sein. Aber vor allem kann man auch eine Menge Spaß haben mit dem Netz und das ist ja auch manchmal ganz wichtig.